brad we got this comment the other day
on our youtube channel and it said
everybody should be paid for their labor
this is especially true in the film
industry
paying your dues quote unquote is a
manipulation tactic used to exploit
newcomers working for free is a good way
to commit career suicide
it will get you labeled as an amateur
and shunned by unions
okay what's your reaction to that but
you know i i know people who who have
that opinion
the dilemma in the film business as
competitive as it is
is
where is the incentive
for an employer in a market that is
overcrowded with experienced people
to pay an inexperienced person
that's the dilemma and you know i
i'm aligned with the ideology of that
statement i think it's a fair
concept yeah but practically you know
this is a business that because of the
competition
you know
people are gonna do what they have to do
to jump ahead and and a quick way that i
know for people to get experience and
build up their resume is to you know
volunteer and work on jobs and you can
certainly do that with your peers and
students
you know but what are you going to learn
from them you know how much knowledge do
they have to pass on how impressive is
that credit gonna be you know i can only
speak for myself but if i was in that
position and i was when i started out my
first job was a freebie i worked on a on
a passion project for some people in
houston and you know they were
professional filmmakers so i would go
out on you know the odd days that they
were shooting and i would volunteer and
and but i was learning from very
experienced people i had the opportunity
to impress those people um
and uh you know so that some of those
people are still friends and i work with
them to this day um likewise on some of
my shoots with you know i support my
friends if a friend of mine says i have
a little short i want to make or i want
to do a spec project you know of course
i'm going to come you know help you and
even if they offer to pay me i i don't
like doing that i don't like charging my
friends for personal projects if it's a
commercial project you know by all means
cut me in um and on things like that for
crews i i typically you know talk to
students and mentees of mine and i say
hey you want to you want to come out and
the reality is that i've had a lot of
people i've done this you know 20 or 30
years and they come out and and you know
the exceptional ones really bust their
butts
and and you know they learn and they pay
attention and they impress everybody and
at the end of the day people are getting
their name and their numbers and you
know somebody calls me and says do you
know a sharp pa we're hiring and i'm
like yeah this person did a great job so
practically i find that
you know
a mechanism that works and if somebody
has a better mechanism if they have a
mechanism by which an inexperienced
person
can get hired and paid over
all the inexperienced people or all the
experienced people who are sitting
around with nothing to do waiting for
that call
i'd love to hear it but but to me that's
the dilemma
right and i i
you know no no disrespect to whoever
left this comment and i get what they're
saying in the sense that especially if
you don't come from a situation where
you can take time off and do free work
not everybody does and i can respect
that that's that's a big factor in a lot
of this
um that you would feel maybe that okay i
might be being used here if i keep
showing up at what point should someone
say okay i've done enough free work or
is there never that point well
it's not about
doing or not doing free work it's about
doing it strategically i'm 30 years into
my career i still do it for my friends
for clients who pay me and say hey i
have a spec spot but i don't have any
money
sure you know i support you know people
this is a business where we scratch each
other's back you know it's a question of
you know are you being taken advantage
of is somebody being predatory um to me
that's that's the thing that you have to
look at and i would say to somebody
who's like oh and the other thing i
wanted to mention too because you're
saying they can't afford to do a free
job um you know having a conversation
just the other day with somebody that
the film industry is a business it's a
business like any business
your time is a commodity and if you have
a business you have to invest in that
business you know part of that is you
know paying union dues paying for head
shots um you know giving your agent 10
i mean you know the professional
organizations and and some of it is the
commodity of your time you know if i
have an opportunity to work with a
director i really want to work with um
because they're doing a a
film competition and i have nothing else
to do to me i'm investing in the
potential of building a relationship
that's going to carry on to paying work
that's my intention now if they keep
calling me for freebies i'm going to be
like well
you know that that well has run dry and
for a new person you ask when do you
stop doing freebies well i would counter
by saying if you're doing nothing but
freebies and not getting called for
paying work you need to look at two
things one
are you doing freebies with amateurs and
people who have no connections or two
are you maybe not doing a good job
because if you are working with
experienced people and you're busting
your ass there's a good chance that
you're going to be getting called for
work and you're going to be getting
referrals
there's exceptions to every rule so you
know
but but i would just say by and large
what i have seen in my years of
mentoring people and also you know again
i feel if somebody comes and donates
their time on my project i owe them
something
and that something is if they do a good
job
i'm gonna i'll give them advice i'll
mentor them i will look out for
opportunities for them i will try and
bring them on paying jobs i will
recommend them you know but conversely
if they come come and they show up and
they and they don't bring it and they
don't do a good job and they don't pay
attention i mean
i appreciate that they tried but i can't
in good conscience send that person to
one of my paying clients because that's
going to reflect on me
that's another thing too is people
always need to remember that if somebody
ever recommends you
they're putting their reputation on the
line so it's not just you know if you
get recommended you don't show up and do
a good job just for yourself you do a
good job for that person who recommended
you because if you do a crappy job
the next time that person wants to make
a recommendation the person is going to
say no that that last last person you
sent me wasn't so good and so somebody
you don't even know is going to miss out
on an opportunity because you set a bad
precedent
do you think it's a generational thing
do you think maybe in the 90s there were
less interns or this is always how the
film industries worked
you know honestly i think it's it's
always how people have worked there's
there's so many stories
you know
probably back into the era of silent
films of people sneaking on set and and
somebody just mistook them for a crew
person and put them to work and and
somebody's like you know eventually they
got paid um
uh you know it's an unorthodox business
and
uh
just by intrinsically it's an unorthodox
business now the perception from people
from the outside is that we're all on
holiday you know i have relatives who
think i sit by the pool and drink frozen
drinks with you know models fanning me
every day that i'm not on set which
isn't true i work harder on those days
you know networking and hustling but um
it's a business and a lot of young
people don't get that they think oh i'm
an artist you know which i get because i
consider myself an artist too but the
rude awakening is that there's a lot of
business in this
um but because it's an unorthodox
business for instance you know i could
show up on work in in a t-shirt and
jeans you know you can't wear flip-flops
because they're unsafe
but but there's not a quote-unquote
dress code although humorously and
anecdotally i'll tell you
there kind of is because no matter where
you go in the world a grip looks like a
grip and a director looks like a
director i don't know what it is man
because i didn't get that memo but i
think it's very funny um
but but you know it's it's an
unconventional business and i think
creativity and originality and
unconventional thinking is is rewarded
and celebrated you know just like when
spielberg you know went and squatted an
office on on the studio backlot you
probably know that story um
and uh you know for instance with
resumes people do resumes if people ever
give me a resume that looks like a
corporate resume i say man that's really
wrong and we we talk about the points
and you know one of the fundamental
points is that this is a creative
business you know
get creative do an interesting font a
creative layout some color
somebody gave me uh advice once which i
thought was brilliant advice i was i was
talking to them i had a meeting and you
know i was uh
talking about you know how should i
present this thing and they said brad
this is show business
put on a show
and i to me that is like an overarching
defining qualification of almost
everything i do
be it a resume or a website or a meeting
you know and putting on a show involves
preparation it involves you know
intention it involves follow-through it
involves thinking on your feet while
it's happening um
and i'm diverging a little bit but the
point that i'm getting back to is that
is that it's it's it's always held its
appeal it's it's always kind of like you
know running off to join the circus um i
think you know there's a certain kind of
people it especially appeals to and
these are
you know people who are in in life maybe
the outcasts or the artists or the
fringe people or you know they think
differently they see the world
differently and that's a valuable asset
in this business and again you know i
had a uh one of my mentees once is a
script supervisor and which she was
starting out you know she got an imdb
pro account and she's uh you know very
attractive young lady and she said i i'm
a little bit of verse to put my photo up
because you know it kind of looks like a
model and i don't want to give the wrong
impression and i said to her
this is a business
where
whatever
whatever advantage you have you play it
you know if you if you qualify for a
diversity program
you know by your gender or your
ethnicity if you like me you've just got
years of experience um you know with her
she's an excellent script supervisor and
that's fine but you know what if
somebody hires her because she's got
a cute photo on imdb pro
you know
as long as they don't abuse and harass
her you know if that pushes her ahead of
the competition and gives her the edge i
say you know anything that is honest and
has integrity um you know you don't want
to cheat and be deceptive or abusive to
anybody but whatever your edge is and
everybody has a different edge i mean i
could have a meeting with a producer and
i've done my due diligence and i'm like
they like to ride horses so
i'm gonna play that up i'm gonna play i
like horses i love horses i've ridden
horses and if that's my advantage so be
it
um
but anyway i'm sorry i believe i strayed
quite
quite a bit from your question
no i love it i love it i love when when
it's sort of a circuitous it goes back
to our original point so yeah probably
going back to vaudeville and yeah the
silent you know
people have been volunteering and then
hey you're hired you know but people ran
away from home for that stuff there was
no you know there was no expectation of
remuneration it was like you know i'm
gonna go join the circus
um and you know some of those people had
really hard lives i mean some of the
people did they have hard lives i've had
some hard weeks and months you know it's
it goes around but um yeah it's a
business where you know again that whole
thing i was talking about in terms of
creativity and originality i mean that's
not necessarily in your visual
expressions that's also in your strategy
you know again spielberg and his office
squatting or
um you know
i go and i speak to college students and
you know two or three come up after
class and say i'd like to intern i'd
like to volunteer you know those are the
guys who who get invited
and sorry what is that spielberg story
i'm not sure i know that one sorry well
i
i wish i knew it a little bit better but
but basically um
he
was able to get on the lot and he just
found an empty office and set up shop
and and it's it's i'm sure the details
are really good but i i don't have them
fresh in my mind it's a legendary story
but that was kind of how he got his
launch before he got his first
opportunity which i believe was a night
gallery episode with joan crawford
it's the one where she plays a blind
lady
um it's a great episode i i wish i could
tell you the the kicker it's got a
little you know twilight zone-esque uh
twist but anybody who wants to see it
i'm not gonna spoil it for him
um but you know it's just it's just that
out of the box thinking you know he
thought of it
and you know
300 of his classmates didn't and whereas
he and where are they
you know and that's just an example and
it
can manifest in so many different ways
just like you know just like the
students i mean one of the things when
i'm speaking to classes that i'm always
tempted to do and i kind of don't
because it's a little cruel but is to
tell people you know look to your left
look to your right in five years those
persons those people are not going to be
in the business
not meeting those specific people but as
a generalization you find that there's
tremendous attrition
for a variety of reasons you know um but
it's it's you know people just it's
you know it's it's a an industry where
staying in the game and pushing forward
in and of itself is an advantage
you know but you just you just always
want that that thing you know to be able
to you know what can i do that nobody
else is doing because if all you're
doing is what everybody else is doing
then then you might as well be a penguin
and a pack of penguins on an iceberg in
antarctica you know you want to be that
penguin you know with the red bow tie
that's jumping up and down and doing
funny stunts because all eyes go there
you know and and that's even true on set
you know just like i said um i always
notice when there's that one pa that oh
you know something needs to be swept up
zip
you know oh they need help moving
something zip can you go wrangle the
background zip and i'm talking about a
real person there's one person that
specifically that that story comes from
you know but i've seen other people do
it but it's like you know that's you
know johnny on the spot person who shows
up before anybody else person who leaves
after everybody else
very simple things you know and they
have nothing to do with
you know what you actually may know
whether you can tighten a c stand or or
fill out a uh deal memo
but it's that attitude it's that
mentality um and and you know again
that's just a different manifestation of
it or if you have that resume that's
just got that super cute
font and it's laid out in a way that
i've never seen before i'm like wow i'm
gonna remember that person so put on a
show
i believe you originally set out to be
a director
i wouldn't say i set out to be a
director you know when i was
first interested in
making films
you know i
spent many years studying fine art fine
art was my passion and it still is my
passion because to me this is fine art
in a different medium
um
but when i originally transitioned into
thinking i might want to do it i as as a
visual artist who is the principal
author i thought well i would want to be
the auteur hence the director and that
made sense to me
and so all through college that was sort
of what i was thinking and then i got
out and my first feature film that i
worked on
i got on set and you know i was hustling
i did all kinds of things over the
period of time this is the job i was
telling you about where i was
volunteering and i was working with
professionals
and the first thing they threw at me
because you know i was a musician i did
a lot of recording so i knew sound so
they had me be the boom operator um and
then the sound guy had days he couldn't
show up because again we're all
volunteering and and that's another
thing about volunteering because of the
attrition you step up pretty quickly
so he trained me how to record sound so
i'm recording sound and you know i
learned grip work and um oh the first ac
can't show up brad you want to pull
focus you know can you run a camera i
mean i went from being the little guy to
you know being the guy that you know a
couple of times it was me and the
director and a wind-up bolex and we were
the crew
so you know that was that was kind of
the thing but when i was on that job and
i was watching that director who's a
friend to this day and i really respect
this guy but
everybody was hitting on him everybody
on set wanted a piece of him you know um
you know
understandably uh you know the actors
wanted his time and the wardrobe people
and the producer and the location people
and it's just like
you know okay and then over here is the
dp now this person has the magic box and
they get to look through the magic box
and make the pretty pictures they get
the lights the toys and i'm thinking now
that
that looks like fun
and um
the funny thing to me is is that was
that was the that was the instinct in
that moment
years later looking at it retroactively
you know i have a lot of interest in
science just a huge science geek i love
history and i love music and of course
visual art
and i was reflecting and i realized that
all of those disciplines
converge in cinematography
you know you've got the art obviously
you've got the science in terms of the
technology the physics um you know
optics things like that you've got
history because you understand you know
the way that that a film was shot in the
20s versus the 40s you understand um you
know the history of cameras and film
grain and digital
because it all plays in and informs your
creative choices you know if i want
something with a little bit of a retro
look i have to understand that history
plus the industry's got a fascinating
history um and then his term in terms of
music i've done a lot of camera
operating and i've come to find that
there are rhythms
even if you're even if you aren't aware
of it nobody's tapping out a drum but in
a scene
in my head i've got a metronome and i'm
like this person that person this person
speaks they grab the glass and i find
there's a rhythm
and
to reinforce this i'll tell you an
interesting story about how i cut my
montages
most people find a piece of music
cut to the beats of the music i never do
that to me it feels artificial it feels
forced
i will cut to the rhythms of the visuals
and then i will find music that fits
those and the thing that is just
profound to me time and again is you
find the right song and it just drops
into place and all those beats hit
um and sometimes you maybe there's a
little nipper tuck here you know
sometimes i might cut the music and
fiddle with it a little bit but and
sometimes the rhythm changes you know
we're all splicing a different piece of
music but literally
all the feature montages on my website
were done that way none of them were cut
to music so so just the rhythm of it and
so all of those things converging it
just made me realize
i'm not i'm not a spiritual person but
but things like that are kind of
profound it's at least magical you know
when the universe conspires
or whatever it is you know even though i
don't embrace anything i don't exclude
anything maybe there is something really
cool out there that put me here um
but uh
yeah that was that was kind of the thing
is that uh you know i i made that
decision i had that impulse on that
first set and then looking back
i was just overwhelmed by by all the
affirmation of why that had been the
right decision
when did you realize that being a
filmmaker in houston texas wasn't the
place for you at that time and then
what happened when you moved here to los
angeles it's a good question so so
obviously i started my career in the
film industry in houston and i had you
know people i worked with who are
mentors and friends
and i still do i've i've been back i've
worked there again
i'm a big supporter of houston and of
texas um i'm an advocate of of the
filmmaking community there and i want to
see it do well
my i have a lot of mentees there to this
day um and i support the community i
just actually was invited to become a
board member for southwest
alternative media project in houston
which is a film advocacy and education
group that's been around since the 70s
so i'm really honored and i feel that
i'm still
a part of that community
but uh what i did realize at the time
was you know because i i knew i wanted
to be a cinematographer that wasn't any
question i've always known what i wanted
to be even when i was a little kid i
knew i wanted to be a garbage man
now i didn't stay wanting to be a
garbage man then i wanted to be an
astronaut but i've never been one of
those people who didn't know so i you
know even though that has swapped out
and and so i knew at that time and i and
i thought about it and there were some
really good cinematographers in in town
and still are and i thought
you know in order for me to get a shot
you know
these guys are going to have to retire
or there's going to have to be more work
and it really became evident to me that
it was a little bit of a closed
ecosystem it was a small market
and i thought
you know
i realized what a sacrifice it was going
to be i realized in terms of my free
time in terms of you know the
volunteering i would have to do to you
know earn my stripes and build my
network and learn my skills um
just in terms of being a freelancer and
not having regular work
um
the uncertainty
you know all of those things and i
realized okay i'm taking a big risk and
that sort of percolated in my brain
and the funny thing is i never made a
calculated decision to leave
one day i walked home i didn't walk on
my drove home
and i walked into the house because yeah
i was living with my parents at 25
because
why not you know i was a filmmaker they
were nice people i loved them and i was
happy to be there
and you know for practical reasons i'm
like
you know i i have no need for that
expense
and i'm content so i stayed there and i
so i walked home i didn't walk home i
keep saying that i drove home and i was
walking into the house and i and i just
i had this
lark that i was just gonna go provoke my
parents i was just gonna tell them that
i was moving to l.a just to get a rise
out of them and i figured they would
talk me out of it
and so i walked in
and um you know there had no there had
been no prelude to this it had never
been discussed before and i walked in
and i said i've decided to move to los
angeles and they said that's wonderful
we completely support you we think
that's
just such a smart decision and and in
that moment i thought oh [ __ ] i've
committed myself i have to follow
through now
because again i you know but the funny
thing is you know just like i say you
know maybe sometimes the universe guides
you because maybe it was just like you
know i got pushed
to where i needed to be in that moment
because again it wasn't a conscious
thing
um
but
i
made plans with a camera assistant
friend of mine you know to to go out and
i'd already had some friends out here um
i had some filmmaker friends and i
thought okay well i'll go and i'll cast
my lot with those people you know none
of them were established they were all
you know wanting to be filmmakers
and i had this one friend who said well
i could come crash on her floor um and
so you know my friend and i made plans
that we would leave in a month
and um started thinking about it like
why are we waiting a month and i was
like let's just go so
two weeks in
we left
so we got there and um you know living
living like uh thieves on the on the
floor
and um
this could be a long story but i'm gonna
i'm gonna i'm gonna fast forward does it
involve the whiskey of gogo sorry
why do i feel like some of that's coming
in well we were i was in venice it was
beautiful my friend lived in a townhouse
okay so but anyway i got there and i had
a lot of delusions i really did i
thought you know um
oh and the other reason that it made
sense to me at the time was that you
know
instead of making all these sacrifices
for this limited market if i'm going to
pay this price
i'm going to go where the sky is the
limit you know that was the logic that
reinforced that decision
so i get out here and i just i made so
many bad assumptions about how i was
going to be welcomed with open arms and
get business and get work and you know
probably 30 000 other people had that
same idea you know and
so i spent i spent some years kind of
aimlessly and
you know to make a living i was doing
temp work in offices um i was doing the
freebies at the time they had this
publication called dramalog which is
kind of like you know the
what craigslist is today a lot of it was
student films but i'm like you know i'm
building a reel i still i had a few
things i'd shot in youtube i didn't have
much of a reel so you know i just needed
more footage and you know even if i'm
working for free somebody else is paying
for the film and the locations and the
camera
um
so i did that for a while um and it was
really dodgy and and at one point i had
this epiphany and i thought you know
all the people i know are at the same
level i am you know we we kind of got
into this and said you know all for one
and one for all we're all going to be
filmmakers
the problem with that is i realized that
if i want to make a living at this i
have to work
with people who do it for a living you
know
and that was a very
transformational
realization for me and when i did that
that's when i started
moving forward and i started you know
applying to companies like concord new
horizons one of my really good buddies
out here um
worked for them and uh he was in the
marketing department but you know he
gave me names and and pointed me in the
right direction and and that's just kind
of how it got started and
you know
from there it took a couple of years and
then i shot some movies for those guys
um you know did some more indies um a
young fellow who i mentored in houston
um ended up blowing up as a huge music
video director and you know through a a
set of circumstances we ended up working
together and that jumped me up some
levels um and then when music videos
kind of subsided i transitioned over you
know the big budgets kind of went away i
transitioned over to commercials and um
and then those kind of evaporated and
and now i'm doing narrative again
so
you probably cut big chunks of that out
no no i love i love the story so that
that's interesting so you're here in la
and you're you're enjoying time with
friends but you looked around and said
what is going to set me apart from these
people and it was that realization
knowing that you were
working with other people that
this was paying their mortgage this was
putting their kids in school and knowing
that they were going to take it very
seriously i don't know i'm paraphrasing
but well i don't know i think that the
whole
set yourself apart realization came a
bit later all i realized was that i was
working with wannabes i was a wannabe my
peers were one of these you know but
wanna be is if it's it's like it's like
entropy you know you're in a vacuum and
and nobody in there has the capacity to
advance you unless you get lucky it's
like the lottery you know do you you
know win a festival award and even then
what does that matter you know so um
this is a business that's very important
to remember you will get
hired to do what you show you can do
so if all you do is freebie low budget
stuff that's what you're gonna get
brought on for if all you do is
volunteer stuff you know that may be
what you get stuck in if all you do is
commercials it's gonna be hard to get a
feature film and even if you do
commercials like me and you got a broad
variety of stuff if somebody wants a car
commercial well they want the car person
they want the one with you know 10 10
car spots or you know the beauty person
i can do all of those things you know
and i have and i can show them but i
don't have the preponderance
and and so that was the thing that you
know just going back to my early my
first experience with that phenomenon
was that i was working with with one of
these people i liked people who were
talented but nobody was in a position to
jump me up to a salaried position and i
had to break outside of that paradigm
you know just end the entropy go to a
completely different model
and that model was to find the people
who were getting paid to do the work and
work with them
and that was really probably one of my
very first significant
realizations of of you know learning the
dynamics in this industry
and we basically are all wannabes when
we start out at something so
i'm still a wannabe
you know there's still things i want to
do i i don't say that that term
maliciously at all it's just you know we
were powerless we had no connections and
nobody was giving us money so you know
it's not a judgment it's just that was
the fact
do you think if you were still moving to
los angeles today that it would take you
five to ten years to
find steady work as a cinematographer
it's hard to say but i'm gonna
go out on a limb and say probably not
the reasons being are that there are
tools today that didn't exist in 1990
you have the internet you have
film industry
groups and
associations you have
um
uh
you know access like when i started
shooting the only way to shoot quality
work was film cameras which were very
expensive and very hard to come by and
the film was expensive and the
processing and tren and the telecini
and if you shot on video it looked cheap
and crappy but even those cameras were
expensive there were no inexpensive home
camcorders um and so it's you know
i could shoot something on my iphone and
you could cut it into an avengers movie
and you would never know
that that is just an incredible paradigm
shift
you know you can cut films on your phone
you can cut them on your computer you
know those things did not exist um you
know now you've got um
youtube and influencers and
web shows uh
and um
you know so many more things now how
long it would take me to crack in you
know to the more professional stuff like
you know feature films uh it's hard to
say but it would be a lot easier to make
quality content it would be a lot easier
to access other filmmakers
you know i mean back in the 90s you know
how how do you find anybody you know i
mean now you just pop on facebook and
you jump in a group and boom there you
go you're surrounded by them you know
and if that if that group is full of a
bunch of shitty
people with bad attitudes you just go to
the next group
you go to multiple groups um yeah it's a
very different
world so i think i think maybe not i
think i think i would have i think it
would happen faster uh you know whether
the big stuff would have happened faster
or not i don't know but i would have
been up and running making films faster
almost for sure
and just as a side note you said you
were crashing on a friend's couch or
floor i was on a floor on a little foam
egg crate
you know the little
mattress toppers and not only that but i
slept i continued to sleep on that for
about a year even when i got my own
place i had a i had a one bedroom in um
at uh vermont and the 101 in koreatown
and and and it was literally a one
bedroom and there was three of us and at
times more because you know we were kind
of the underground railroad for houston
when people would come out i'd be like
come on out and i and i paid forward my
friend's offer where she said um you
know you can come out and stay for free
for a month and that was kind of my
policy is you can come out you stay for
free for a month give you time to you
know find a job and a place and and you
know get you know get in a place where
where you're comfortable and secure
and i think you know we helped some
people you know get their starts that
way i'm very proud of that
what's the strangest part-time job you
had on unrelated to film
during that time
during that time
i
probably
there was some
job that i only vaguely remember but
this guy would pay me
to go and audiotape like school plays or
musicals on a little cassette recorder
in retrospect i'm just like what was
that all about i don't even really
remember it but but it happened so yeah
that was the strangest thing really
interesting where'd you find that job
i don't even remember much about the job
i have no idea
what did roger corman teach you about
the business of filmmaking
well roger corman personally and
directly taught me nothing because i
didn't work i never worked with roger
i met roger and he's a really nice guy
and he's like a big kid he was so
excited about this
cheesy monster that somebody had
repurposed you know very affordably
i think he was more excited that you
know they had
repurposed it for next to nothing than
you know what they had actually produced
with it but you know
he had a very
i'm sure he still does have a very uh
sparkly and wonderful personality and
this deep mellifluous voice that you
could just you know keep talking roger
that sounds great um
but in terms of the precedent that he
set at the studio he ran new concord new
horizons um
it definitely taught me a lot of things
because you know it was it was you know
it was called colloquially concord
school of film or roger corman's school
of film
and um and it really was a lot of people
got their starts there you know you go
they weren't always concord because he
had new world and some other other
things but he gave his he gave starts to
people like you know ron howard got his
first directing opportunity um you know
dennis hopper worked for him uh galen
hur jim cameron i mean these are they're
all way before me of course but you know
they're in in that in that in that realm
of of of roger corman and
you know there wasn't a lot of of money
he he has this book that's titled how i
made
you know
200 movies i forget the number 200
movies never lost a dime
um you know he would do things like uh
you know get martin sheen
and you know he'd be on the cover of the
the video box and then you realize what
actually happened is that roger paid him
for one day and they shot little scenes
that they cut in through the movie you
know that's smart you know people buy a
movie because martin sheen's on the
cover well there you go um so you know i
learned things like that um
i
i remember
that
and this wasn't me this was my friend
who worked in marketing they would send
him out with a clipboard into malls and
they would just have these titles of
non-existent films
and he would ask people you know which
which movie would you go see
which is interesting because that's how
sharknado originated they had the title
they didn't even have
the
the script and i know the fellow who
wrote that and he said they when they
decided to make it they conceived it as
a straightforward
you know serious movie and he said he
said no that's this is this is something
we've got to have fun with
and and somehow he got them to trust him
and it became what it became
but you know again things like that you
know things like you know what really
sells a movie you know is it the fact
that i take great pictures or this
person does great acting i mean you know
i think that's what brings a movie home
you know but what gets the butt in the
seat is the title or the fact that
martin sheen's in it um from a practical
point of view i remember meeting the
producer at the studio on my first job
and he said took me into his office and
he said brett
every day you can pick one scene to make
look really good
beyond that just make your day
and you know being a very
proud artist you know i'm like okay i've
got to game the system how do i make
them all look really good
and and so i was coloring outside the
lines i mean what's the you know what
can i do you know that that's you know
outside of the normal parameters and one
of the things i came up with was that i
would show up to set every day
an hour or two early
and i would do diagrams i would go and i
would be in the set without blocking or
anything but i have a sense you know of
what it was i i probably had gone with
the director and talked talked through
it i don't remember that but i probably
did
um but anyway i went in there and i
would place some lights i would
on my diagram i would be like you know
this is the lighting scheme in here and
that's the lighting scheme in there and
i would go through all the sets because
they were you know those sets on the
soundstage
and then when the crew would get there
um you know i would walk them through
the sets and the first set we would we
would get it lit and then after that if
i didn't have time i would just hand
them the diagram and say here go set
this up so i was
micromanaging them and i would have them
light two and three sets ahead now the
limitation with that is you have to have
the equipment but this was a studio the
equipment was laying around
and this is something that i've always
incorporated you know any time that i
that i am able to you know i sell that
to people is i will
move faster if you give me the equipment
to pre-light so i'm not going into a
room and starting at square one that
you're walking in and it's roughed in we
just have to tweak and shoot
so you know that was one of the
advantages and part of that reason was
because literally to my astonishment i
would i when we were shooting i would
walk into the bathroom and i would no
sooner have stopped and gotten ready to
do my business then the door would open
or ba would be saying we want you on set
you know i mean i just had no time so i
had how do you how do you hedge that bet
and that was you know one of the things
i did um another thing that i did
because we often didn't have the thing
we needed um you have to think out of
the box how can i do this differently if
i don't have dolly track if i don't have
that light if i don't have the cucularis
if i don't have the thing i need to do
the thing how do i make it work
so it got me thinking really creatively
and sometimes you completely reconceive
a shot
you know and and sometimes that
challenge makes that shot even better
you know and um
so so that's just you know that's a just
a really a revelation but also it got me
into the habit of where you know if i
needed something to break up light and i
didn't have it um you know or whatever i
needed i would just go walk around the
studio which was an old lumber yard and
i would look in trash cans and in
corners and i would find these little
treasures i'm like i can use this
and it's funny because years later i was
working on torque for warner brothers
which is a 55 million dollar action
movie i was shooting second unit
and uh
i had uh martin henderson was the lead
actor and i had a scene with him
and the light was too clean on his face
i wanted to break it up
and i had these you know really
experienced veteran grips
and i had this huge 10-ton grip truck
outside
and they're like what about this what
about this what about this and i'm like
no no no no no those things are right
and so i i walked around i just walked
around and i found this old
raggedy plastic
c47 bag you know clothespin bag and i
was looking i was like you know what
this is and i and i walked up and we had
a leco on his face and i put it in there
it was just perfect you know very subtle
but it it took the edge off the light
and i'm like this is it and these guys
are looking at me like i'm crazy and you
know they bring a c-stand and they clamp
it and they thought it was so funny they
found a spare pelican case and they you
know they called it the
x-z-47 or whatever and that was now that
was on the truck
but but you know it's it's you know
it's it's easy to take the thing off the
shelf and to use it
you know i mean anybody can do that
but um i i really
am very happy that i got pushed into
that position
of learning to macgyver learn to
appropriate
you know what was handy i was on a shoot
just the other day
and uh
we were shooting an interview with
somebody and in the background there was
this white pole
and you know everybody's freaking out we
don't want to see it can you go with a
different angle and you know there was
angles which showed sliding glass doors
or the light was bad on the actor's face
and i just took some two-inch get black
gaff tape and literally just put it on
the face of the pole towards the camera
another one of my favorite stories is i
did this video with um rob thomas called
lonely no more
and
there was a scene with him in close up
and he's got these shiny glasses on and
i wanted a reflection in the glasses
and we did not have a because they're
convex you know they show a pretty you
know wide degree of range i didn't have
anything white
wide enough that you didn't see the end
of it
and in a moment i said you know what get
me
some a roll of paper towels and a c
stand and i took that roll of paper
towels i put it on the c stand i just
went
i raised the c stand up and if you see
that video if you go to my website
and you'll see this the thumbnail for it
has this white line it's toilet it's a
paper towels
so
i could give you so many more examples
of that but those are the kind of things
you know when you don't have the stuff
when you don't have the thing when
you're shooting low budget you know when
you're challenged when you don't have
the time you know don't don't don't
think of it as a handicap embrace it as
a challenge because
really it will make you a better
filmmaker and and sometimes maybe more
often than not what you come up with
will be even better than if you had the
thing to pull off the shelf
and when you do have free time do you go
to swap meets or thrift stores and look
for things where you because it sounds
like you just have this keen eye for
like
intuitively you know what's gonna work i
i don't i mean for me it's it's an in
the moment kind of thing i mean if i if
i saw something like um
you know every once in a while i've
bought
you know little lights and little
tchotchkes but i don't um
i don't i don't go looking for it i do
try to balance my time you know and not
be in work mode
all the time although i am a little bit
of a workaholic when it comes to you
know both networking and also mentoring
i probably push myself a little more
than i ought to i've gotta you know find
that balance again with personal time
but
but um
yeah it's uh i've had a few dreams in my
in my life where you know i would i
would wait you know i would be dreaming
that i was on a set and i
and a light was broken or missing and i
would just get so worried about you know
how do we fix it and how do we and then
i wake up and i'm like
i have to have this conversation with
myself that it was a dream because i'm
so upset
and so involved you know or those dreams
where you dream that you're on set and
then you wake up and it's time to go to
set you know it's
you know so i try and i try and i try
and not be on the clock
24 7.
after a number of years of shooting low
budget indies you left that world to
begin shooting
music videos
why was that the right decision for you
at that time
you know a door opened and it was a
terrific opportunity to work with a
really talented director who was also a
friend
you know and
and i one thing i love about this
business is always something new you
know i'm not
even if i'm just doing features you know
one's a sci-fi and one's a horror and
one's a romantic comedy you know and and
as much as i love the people i work with
you know i work with different people
all the time and i love them all equally
you know so it's there's just this
variety
um and you know to be able to explore
high-end music videos was just
irresistible and and i i loved it and
i'm very grateful i had that opportunity
it really you know shifted the shift to
the the dynamic for me
but then at some point you stop doing
music videos can you talk about what
happened i haven't really ever stopped
doing music videos i mean what happened
is that the music video industry changed
um
from my point of view it was
precipitated initially by by napster um
you know people
illegally downloading videos um and then
everything that followed um you know all
the way to today where you've got
streaming where you know apparently the
revenue to the artists and the labels is
you know nothing compared what it used
to be
um
but anyway because of that that that
shift
in in the financial aspects of that
industry
people started dialing back on
the the size of the budgets the number
of the videos um you know even at the
time i wondered how much of this is is
real because they don't have the beans
to count to make it happen and how much
of it is opportunistic where somebody's
taking advantage of this you know to
just slash costs and you know knock us
all down
right before that happened they had
finally you know a lot of the production
companies had finally signed um become
signatory with ayatsi
which you know you could look at it and
say wow you know that's kind of a weird
thing that you know right after that
happened we suddenly had this
you know this this crisis with funding
them but
but i don't know i'm not a conspiracy
guy and and frankly i'm an optimist and
i i tend to assume the best in people
until proven otherwise so
at least in my brain it's just that's
the way the cookie crumbled and and i
still do music videos it's just they
don't have the budgets they don't have
you know as high a profile they're
they're super fun you know i love them
um and same with commercials i mean i
there was a time when i just made a
fortune shooting commercials and
sure there's still big commercials out
there and every once in a while i get
one um but i it just seems like again
that the the model for that market
changed significantly and and either by
virtue of the realities or opportunism
or a combination of both it's it's
changed and and and one thing that i
tell young people about this business
you know there's not many things in this
business that are a constant
but one of the things that is a constant
is change
you know whether it's the dynamic in the
markets whether it's the prevalence of
one genre over another whether it's a
certain style of cinematography whether
it's you know film cameras or digital
cameras or hd or 4k or 8k
you know it's always going to change so
hopefully you enjoy that i do
can you compare and contrast where you
were
creatively emotionally when you were
working on these low budget indies
to when you went to these higher budget
music videos with name talent
how was that
um
it's interesting because because on a
certain level
artistically i was ready
for sure
but in terms of confidence and
knowledge of the politics and dynamics
it was it was a learning curve
and i remember calling one of my mentors
stephen poster and i asked him
because i had this one i had this mariah
carey music video
and we were shooting this intersection
downtown and we had this car explosion
it was this huge a-list movie kind of
lighting setup
and i said you know i'm a little bit
nervous because you know i've i've lit
stuff before i've let movies and i've
lit some big music videos but you know
they were all you know houses or or um
you know offices or
stages or
um
uh
you know cars
just things that um
you know never an entire bloody city
street and i'm just you know i was i was
a little anxious and he says
you know brad the thing to think about
is that everything you know about
lighting still applies it's just a
different scale
you know i mean a backlight is a
backlight and a side light as a side
light and and i and and he really made a
lot of sense and
i'm sure he was much more thorough than
that but those are the broad strokes i
remember and the other thing he said is
you know make sure you have a really
good gaffer
and that's true and i had an excellent
gaffer so so it all came together and it
was fine
and that underscores something and i it
wasn't that moment that i realized it
but it that was one of the moments that
reinforced it was to always have a great
crew you know have a great team behind
you
it's interesting to me that there are
some people in this business who feel
they have to be the smartest person in
the room
uh or they're intimidated and i'm just
i'm the opposite i'm like you know i
want people who know more about
their job and their responsibility than
i do it's important that i know a little
bit about it so i know what i'm asking
of them and how long it'll take and what
it'll cost
um you know but but all the little bits
and pieces you know i really want
somebody who has much more experience
and one of the things i like to say to
people about the cruise that i bring on
is that if if we're on set and i fall
over dead you'll still make your day on
time and on budget because that's just
how good these people are
is that real a real thing though that
some would hire down so to speak
because they feel that they would be
challenged so i think so i i don't know
where they would actually hire it but i
know i know people who are resentful and
they want to feel like they know it all
you know
it's it's just a phenomenon so then if
someone is on a set like that and they
know that's the person i'm working with
how do i stay small for the day
so that i don't ruffle feathers i don't
think it's a matter of staying small i
think it's just a matter of you know
doing your job and just not challenging
that
you know i mean
if they say you know that that this is
their idea you just nod your head and be
like okay sure you know um i mean there
are people who would have a
pride and want to stand up for
themselves and if there's a strategic
reason for that okay maybe but if
there's no strategic reason then i'm a
big believer and it really doesn't
matter who's right you know it's that's
a horrible thing for me to have to fight
for i i would much rather do the thing
right and get the thing right and if if
somebody else has to take credit for it
you know so be it and if and if they do
it a lot and i really hate it then why
just stop working with that person
you know but but confronting them and
challenging them i'm just not sure
there's any value in doing something
like that
so the best is just nod
and and do as they ask and then
if at the end of the shoot you realize
this might not be something i want to
continue with that's one thing but just
to save just for conflict's sake well
unless there's a a strategic reason not
to safety would be a good reason not to
you know there may be a strategic reason
there may be a dynamic or a relationship
i'm not taking into account in somebody
else's circumstances but just for me in
my experiences i've never had a reason
to not do that i've never had a reason
where i thought okay you know there's
going to be value in pushing back on
this you know it's it's to me it's
always like you know let's get the job
done let's let's do it right let's you
know make the client happy you know
let's get paid let's go home and work
another day
brad how did life change for you when
the high-end
music video market crashed
how scary was this i was very distracted
when that happened because i was in a
relationship that was ending
after like 13 years and
it was contentious circumstances
from my point of view
and i felt a lot of betrayal in terms of
you know trusting people i probably
should not have trusted
and and it affected a lot of things for
me and so i was kind of in survival mode
um and and
i don't know that i was as engaged with
that aspect of my job at the time i mean
i was certainly still working and very
happily i dovetailed into
you know doing a lot of commercials and
promos so so
my income really didn't take a hit which
was really an act of grace because i was
not in an emotional place to deal with
you know yet another monkey wrench
um
you know but life's like that you know
we we do our jobs and we have that
our career reality and then we have our
personal reality whether it's
um you know happy things like people
having kids or sad things like people
breaking up and parents dying
um you know that's life and everybody
everybody has that
um
but you know i have always landed on my
feet i really have and and i am very
grateful
um that i've always been able to pivot
you know i've got a broad set of skills
and part of that's intentional there are
people who you know have the theory that
you should specialize you know again
like those people who do
the car commercials or the beauty
commercials um you know back for a while
that that kind of green blue
cinematography look was a thing and i
intentionally didn't do a lot of that
because if you're the guy who does that
when the day comes that it's past say so
are you
and then like i had told you earlier you
tend to get hired to do what you show
you can do so i deliberately
intentionally
created a body of work that is diverse
and represents the genres and types of
things i like to do and if you look at
my website which is only at the tip of
the iceberg all my work is on vimeo you
know
password protected so i can show it if i
need to
but but the work that's on my website is
honestly that i want to do more of that
kind of work you know it's intentional
um
so
you know again i i was very happy and
fortunate to land on my feet
you know just like the beatles say with
a little help from my friends which is
very true
um
and uh
did some really wonderful work i was
just a new phase of life for me in a in
a lot of ways but it it became a very
happy and rewarding phase i mean some of
the best work i feel i did was during
that period
you know i feel that uh i don't want to
be perceived as perfect i don't want to
be perceived as as not having problems i
i mentor a lot of young people and i
think it's important for them to
understand that i'm human and that i'm
vulnerable and that i have setbacks and
challenges because i don't want them to
look at my career as an example and say
you know oh wow i want that but but you
know that guy's invincible you know i
want them when they look at themselves
and say you know i'm i'm
unsure or i'm hurting or i don't have
the money or you know whatever their
liability is i want them to look at me
and say well you know he overcame
something so i can too that's the kind
of example i want to be so i'm very
happy airing my dirty laundry
do you think there's a lot of pressure
in this industry to to appear as if
one's life is perfect until
unfortunately some cracks come out and
if someone's on a certain level now it's
in
horrible tabloids and everybody can take
their stance on twitter and yeah i know
for a fact there is i mean you know
again this is a
an image-driven industry and again this
goes back to that whole thing about its
show business put on a show
i'm very intentional about what dirty
laundry i air but you know just like
just like you don't post on facebook and
and say you woke up with a sick stomach
and
and um you know you're mad at your boss
i you know maybe some people do some of
the time but you you know you're
judicious about that kind of thing you
know and and it is a business where we
all want to be perceived as working and
in demand but i don't think the reality
for most of us is that we always are
you know i mean i think the reality for
us all is that we have ups and downs and
we have really good runs and then we
have some frustrating slow periods and
i'm sympathetic to that for everybody
and i'm very grateful when i have when i
have a run and i'm not resentful if i'm
slow and other people are working i'm
glad they're having their moment um you
know but i think there are people and
and i understand it you know that you
give that impression um
for for whatever reason
when you're busy you tend to get more
calls and work so you you put on the
impression of
of being busy and it's quite easy
because you know um as long as you have
stuff and you're sharing you know and
again this is something that didn't
exist
in the 90s when i first came out here
but you know you you're your own
publicity machine and you're like oh you
know festival award and and oh interview
and and this movie is coming out on
netflix it makes you look really busy
you might not have worked for six months
they don't know that i mean you know you
don't shoot a movie and it comes out the
next day
so but you just you manage that you
manage that impression and i do i do i
mean i honestly do um you know i don't
wanna i don't wanna i never wanna see
even even if i'm even if i'm you know
being
candid about my vulnerability or my
setbacks you know i never want it to be
a complaint or an excuse
because i don't think it should be i
mean i think you know
the only reason i do it is i just want
to humanize myself for anybody who might
be looking at me as an example because i
don't i always want them to feel that
the things i say and the things they may
see that i've achieved i want them to
feel that that's accessible for them too
how do you keep faith in yourself and in
your craft during
turbulent times
boy is that a good question talk about
dirty laundry um
you know there was
i have this terrific career coach and
her name is erica wernick she's really
fabulous i highly you should do an
interview with her you really should
she's just got a book coming out oh now
i'll send you her information but please
but you know she would probably you know
punch me in the arm for saying this but
there was a time in my career
early on in the 90s where i was so
frustrated
and and so down and didn't believe in
myself and i just had this revelation i
was like you know what i've set a goal
and i don't have to believe in myself
i just have to do the steps that i
committed to doing
to get me through
the valley of the shadow of death
and and that worked for me and it was a
device that worked for me and and i feel
like occasionally i still have it i mean
i think a lot of people
you know like erica talk about how
important it is you know to believe in
yourself and to believe that your
success is inevitable and that's also
very powerful
i just find that that my brain is a
little more complex in terms of
the things it does to me you know i
don't know that i'm always in the
driver's seat and
quite honestly i i deal with self-esteem
issues i really do i mean i think a lot
of people do in this business you know
your identity is tied up in your work
even if you don't want it to be because
you put so much of yourself into it and
if it doesn't do well or even if it does
well i mean
honestly the irony to me of having
something successful and praised
and then not having a lot of work that's
even worse than having something
criticized because because at least if
they criticize that you're like okay it
sucked i get it but if they say it's
awesome and then
the jobs don't follow you're like
you know where's where's the karma
where's the payoff uh you know we made a
deal
so so that's harder for me um
but uh
um
i do try to keep faith in myself and and
and you know honestly when when i when i
do have
crises with the system or
success is a nebulous thing
i i really i get basic and i go back and
i remind myself you know brad you're an
artist
that was the contract you made you never
said you wanted to be rich i don't care
about being rich i would like to be
self-sufficient i'd like to be secure
you know and if i was rich it'd be okay
but i'd be donating and
helping and i mean i'm just
i just don't need a super yacht and an
island um
but you know i remind myself that the
contract that i made was that i wanted
to be an artist simple
as that and you know what
i am i mean i just i look at the work
i've done i work at the the work i'm
doing and even if these people don't
like it or those people don't like it or
even if everybody likes it and i don't
get a job or an award it's like you know
what you gotta
do the work you know somebody gave you
the toys somebody gave you the sandbox
and they let you build your sandcastle
and and that's enough
do you think a lot of success is luck
or success can be orchestrated
i want to believe it can be orchestrated
you know and i know
you know people who who feel very
strongly about that and and i feel
i feel it can be influenced
you know i don't know if i believe it
can be orchestrated in a guaranteed way
because because for for a hundred people
doing a hundred
things
more or less the same they're going to
have different outcomes
you know because they'll know different
people they'll be at different moments
in time it'll be a different project um
you know they may have a different
mode to their personality or their
energy or you know i don't know i mean
it could be simple simple things
you know
i give you an example i mean i have
people who message me out of the blue
and if people message me and they have a
specific question and they say brad what
light did you use in that particular
scene or they say um you know would you
look at my resume
i respond to them you know
people who who hit me up and they say
how are you doing i just don't even
answer because
how do i i don't i don't need any small
talk and how do i answer that
you know it's like
so so the point being is that is that um
you know the way
you interact with the world be it me
or be it those person persons emailing
me you're gonna get a different response
depending depending on what you put out
there
and i've forgotten your question but i
hope i answered it oh you did you did i
think you said it because i was saying
is a success do you think a lot of it's
luck or it can be orchestrated and so it
sounds like it might be sort of a
combination it's it's got to be it
really has to be because because
you know it's it's
what is it they say success is is
preparation meeting opportunity right
you know you have to be prepared you
know if you go into that meeting if you
luck out and you get that meeting but
you you don't know squat you're not
going to impress them
but if you are a genius and you're an
introvert and won't go out and do the
meetings then you're still stuck and
just for anybody who's an introvert i am
a terrible introvert i am so shy
but i want this more than i want to be
shy so i just you know i'm not an actor
but in that way i am an actor you know i
will i will go do the act and i'm not
always good you know if i'm in a crowd
and i don't anybody and i don't have a
wingman that's kryptonite i shut down
and i sit in a corner to this day i'm
ashamed of it but i just i'm just i
powerless
but you know i know to have a wingman i
don't have somebody else to help me you
know or at least find oh i know that
person they can introduce me you know i
mean that's you know um but you know
when i was a little kid i um
you know i would just my mom would say
you know you want to you want a slurpee
and and she would you know i'd be
sitting in the car and and she said we
have to go in and get it i would just
sit there and cry because i didn't want
to go in
by myself i was so shy
um but so it was it's hard you know
but uh
you know you just
if you want something enough then you do
the things you need to do one of my
favorite sayings right now and because
i'm looking to level up i mean look i
could be at the top and i'd still be
looking to level up
but there's this great saying and it's
if you want something you've never had
before
you have to do something you've never
done before
and sometimes that might be obvious but
sometimes it's surprising like just the
other day i had this realization because
i'm a workaholic and i drive myself like
crazy
i was reading erica's book as a matter
of fact
meant for this go out and buy it it's a
really good book
but i had a thought that was really kind
of a non-sequitur it wasn't really
relevant to what i was reading but i
thought i thought brad
you need
quiet time you need to stop
and just be quiet whether you meditate
or or just watch the world go by because
you don't do that
and that's surprising because my logical
brain says well that's not going to get
you anywhere
but then i start thinking you know
because i know that that you just can't
go 24 hours even though i have
because you wear down you you lose your
acuity
so so
you maybe that is the thing maybe i need
more breaks and more quiet time because
maybe that will make the time i do spend
working
just that more focused and that more
effective you know
um
you know it's better to to spend five
really effective minutes than than an
hour kind of unfocused and tired and
distracted
so so that was the thing that i thought
well you know that's interesting because
that's a thing i haven't done before and
it's it's not what i would have guessed
you know but that's that's just kind of
the thing is is that um
um
you know and and the other thing about
success is people when people ask advice
for about success or about being a
cinematographer or being on set or
meeting people or networking
everybody wants the formula they want
the road map they want the a b c equals
d
and i get that because as humans i think
we're wired that way i want that but
guess what i've never found it um it's
just it's just always different it's a
moving target and and you learn as you
go and you you
take your best guess and you try it
and if it doesn't work then you're like
okay it's not working i'm not gonna quit
but let me try something different let
me revise it can i go this way can i go
that way can i show up with flowers and
chocolate can i you know get my buddy to
do an introduction you know
whatever you know it's not about
stopping it's about it's about okay this
isn't working let's
think of something else let's reinvent
and even something that does work for a
while just like the market changes just
like the technology changes it's like
you know what
it used to work it's not working now
try something different
so being internal an introvert maybe
needing quiet time did that work for you
growing up in houston
and how did you turn that like if you
needed to turn on that and i'm just i'm
just stereotyping here the southern
charm and being sort of you know larger
than life which you do have that side to
you i can see it but how would you
manifest that if you had to walk into a
room and sort of own it
if i know people it's easy you know if i
know some people it's easy
um but part of it is having generosity
towards the other person
i think that um
one of the things that i tell young
people is is if you approach a
relationship if you want a meeting or
you want to connect with somebody
do not approach it from what can they do
for me i am going to ask them for a job
i am going to ask them to give me
something
the best way to approach it is to be
like what can i give them
you know what do i have to offer
and and um
you don't have to be an experienced
filmmaker we are blessed with social
media where we consider this person
likes going out on a boat this person
likes dogs and that person likes to
paint
and this person maybe went to your
school
and this person maybe
is friends with your
uncle
i don't know but we have the ability to
do due diligence on people in a way that
has
just never been possible before
i do that and i recommend that people do
that you know and you go and you you do
your homework and then they're not a
stranger you know because you have you
find that thing oh you know they like
comic books or oh they like this their
favorite movie is my favorite movie or
or they like the same band i like
that takes a lot
of the the edge off of
because the part of the fear is like i
don't know what to say
but you know if you guys both like
doberman pinschers now you have
something to talk about and and it's
lovely for the other person because you
know what all day long they're getting
calls oh give me a job you know i want
to be a pa will you make my movie
and they're like oh you want to talk
about my dog oh here's a picture of my
dog they're so happy you know and that's
that's the thing because you have to
remember this is a business of
relationships it's not a business of of
like parasites and and and and prey
you know it's it's it's your friends you
want you want to work with your friends
you're going to call your friends you're
going to work with your friends
everybody likes hanging out with their
friends you know and this is a business
where you have the ability to hire the
people you like
you know
and and you know people who are it's
just like in your life think about you
know that one friend who always asks you
for something they always want you to
come over to their house and do them a
favor and and and buy lunch and they
never reciprocate how excited are you to
spend time with that person you know but
think about the other person who calls
you up and says oh there's this new
movie and you would love it you know
that's the person you're happy to hear
from so
you know when i meet with people i try
to be able to offer that and also when i
follow up and in social media i'm like
oh hey here's an article i know you like
butterflies here's a butterfly article
um
and and it's not just um
you know a cynical thing because because
i think it's cool that they like
butterflies it's neat so that's cool um
so when i'm in a in a
position of meeting people one of the
things that that mindset
precipitates is that it makes you listen
because you don't know what people want
if you don't listen to them
and a lot of people will tell you that
in meetings you don't want to do a lot
of talking you want to listen
and then talk strategically and and to
the point and so i think if you listen
you know people are going to tell you of
their story and they're going to tell
you what they need and i've had that
many times where they're like oh and i
was on the shoot and there was this
thing and i'm like oh yeah well you know
the next time you have that happen let
me know because i know a guy you know or
oh well let me tell you what i did once
in a similar situation
um and and i think that's you know again
you're being friends and i literally
years ago stopped
leading with my website like the most
aggressive thing i'll do now is put it
in my signature
because if people are interested they're
going to look for it you know
i reach out and talk to them about their
doberman pinscher or their horse or
their butterflies i mean that's how i
build it or i compliment them like oh
you know that commercial you did was
really beautiful or oh hey you know i'm
also friends with so and so um
and you know i'll do i've done lunches
with people you know and we spend you
know and this is somebody that yeah i'd
love to work with them and we spend the
whole lunch talking about nothing having
even remotely to do with film
and as we're
getting up to leave
they say
send me your work i might have something
coming up you know but how much more
powerful is it for them to ask
than for me to be like oh you know look
at my stuff
you know because they get that all day
long again you know you just don't want
to be that person i don't want to be
that maybe somebody does but i don't
want to be that person so so that's how
i handled it i i fee it and it also it
takes the pressure off i have nothing to
prove i'm not selling anything i'm not a
salesman i would be a horrible salesman
you know but i'm pretty i'm pretty good
at being nice to people i'm pretty good
i mean something i care a lot about is
is other people is you know how can i
help them what up and you know again
maybe it's not even me maybe it's like
oh you should meet this person i'm
really good about that you know just be
a matchmaker of of like oh these two
people need to meet and sometimes it's
obvious why they should meet and
sometimes it's just like y'all have
similar personalities and i don't know
what's going to come of it but you
should know each other
so
that's that's my answer to your question
as a shy person you know how do you go
in there is i i go in there with a sense
of generosity and relating as a human as
opposed to a salesperson
one of the quotes on your imdb page
is evolve study your strategies versus
results and adjust course pay attention
to what works for your peers and those
who have come before ask for advice from
experienced filmmakers definitely do not
keep pursuing a course of action that is
producing no results or poor results
and i've seen so many people ruin their
careers because they were inflexible and
unable to adapt yeah
so first off did you is that is that one
of your sort of mottos did you read that
somewhere that's me that's you that's
honest i mean that's just that and i
picture those people in my head i'm not
going to tell you who they are right
thank you okay
but but so that's like the 30 years
culmination of
from sleeping on the egg crate to
working on
high-end music videos and film and
and seeing you know
you know
the ability to
[Music]
grow
and adapt
and revise your
model inside your head
the more you're malleable
the more you're liable for success
the more that you're rigid
the more that you're right
the more that you have a liability for
failure
because the world
none of us
know how the world works
we have clues we have ideas we have
experiences based on our past and things
that people tell us
but as humans our perceptions are not
we don't perceive reality you know our
sensory organs
give us you know photons and audio
vibrations that go into the circuitry of
our brains and our biology
manipulates it and and and just the the
subtleties in the human psyche and
cross wires or whatever it is none of us
looks at anything a hundred percent
objectively though we may think we do
we color it we
filter it we make assumptions based on
prior experience and the best you can do
is to to try and learn when and where
that's happening and and try and
counteract it
you know
but it's not 100 possible you know i
mean i just i know that that's why
you've probably heard me say a few times
that it's like well that's my perception
and my experience i'm not going to tell
you that's the way it is because i don't
believe that's the way it is it's how i
experienced it in that moment and that's
all i can articulate to you
you know you should also ask this person
and that person and trust your own
senses
and and i think that
in doing that you get a better picture
because it's like oh they saw it a
little differently and i saw a little
differently and so you kind of
synthesize um you know it's it's it's um
you know it's a fuzzy thing it's like
what what is it possibly um
you know but but
the people i see fail are the ones who
who
well not all of them but some of the
people i see phil are the ones who have
this rigid idea
that it works like this you do this you
do this you do this and that happens
and when one of those things fails to
produce it's like
you know
hollywood hates me people are evil you
know the system is rigged against me um
you know i'm unlucky i'm a victim
whatever you know and that's just not
empowering
and even even if somebody really did do
a thing against you even if somebody
intentionally boned you
um tripped you
you know even if you met somebody and it
really was rigged if you surrender to
victimhood
you've given up your power
you know even if it's true
don't accept the role except
you know
accept that you have the power and and
maybe you just don't go that way maybe
you go this way or maybe you go that way
again that's the malleability it's like
it's like okay i thought that was gonna
work it didn't work i bashed my head i
tripped
somebody either did or did not
deliberately
thwart me
that's all beside the point what am i
going to do now
but i've just seen people who have that
rigidity of thinking you know or that
assumption that somebody else is
persecuting them
again whether it's true or not really
doesn't matter
are you going to be empowered in that
moment
to divert
or are you going to be stopped that's a
choice you have to make and and i'm not
going to judge anybody based on their
choice it makes me sad
if if that keeps them from what they
want
but it's their choice to make and i
respect that
so if someone is or isn't being
kept from
gatekeepers whomever from succeeding in
their mind
how do they say okay maybe that's true
maybe it's not but i'm not going to
accept that that's going to keep me down
i'm not going to i.e except the
victimhood
what are they doing to get i realize
each situation will be specific but
sort of what kind of mindset aside from
that what kind of action are they taking
to make sure they don't stay in that
victimhood
well one of the things that you can do
first of all is not consider yourself an
island
and by that i go back to my example
where i said you're standing there and
and i tell you something but what did
that person see what did you see so
don't
keep it all here
ask this person ask this person you know
you've got a team we're all a team we
all have each other's backs if you don't
have friends like that you've got the
wrong friends this is a business this is
a industry as an artist
you need your posse you need the people
who believe in you you need the people
who hold you accountable to do the
things you say you will do and follow
through and will gently call you when
you don't
and you need the people that when you
are in that moment and you are stuck and
you feel that
something has stopped you or someone has
stopped you or you made a mistake
you can say i i just i don't know what
to do do you can what do you think give
me some advice
you know
and and you can do it with peers but
this is also where mentors are really
important reach out to the people who
are successful doing what you need to do
because you know why
they've done it
they know how to make it happen
again they can't give you the roadmap
because you will not take the same path
you will not meet the same people
but bits and pieces of what they say
will apply and they have had peers
who've had different experiences they're
going to be able to give you advice and
answers
and again this is why i say people
should have more than one mentor
because every you know everyone's going
to give you different advice and it
doesn't mean that one person's advice is
better than another's it's all based on
their life experience but if you have a
variety you have a variety of
possibilities you have chocolate vanilla
and strawberry you know they're all good
you know but which one is right in that
moment for you
um so so so that's what i would tell
them to do is is just is just is is
reach outside yourself you know seek
advice consult your mentors consult your
friends um
you know google it
put a put a post on a filmmaking board
with complete strangers here's my
challenge what do you suggest
you know throw it out to the universe
and see what the universe
throws back maybe and maybe you have a
better idea than anything i said please
share that with me when you think of it
but um you know to me there's always
possibilities there's always
there's always in life there's always
that thing we've overlooked
you know no matter what we consider you
know if if life gives us a b and c
there's always secret answer number d we
may not know what it is you know but we
can look for it we can go to our peers
and our mentors to try and figure it out
and there may also be you know secret
number secret answer e f and g
i don't know but i refuse if if i look
at the at the evidence
and it does not permit me to continue
toward my goal
then then i declare that that's
incomplete evident
and and and just because i don't see it
doesn't mean it doesn't exist
so rigidity
kills careers
i don't think it kills i'm not going to
say i wouldn't be so absolutist to say
that rigidity kills creators but i would
say that that rigidity hobbles options
you know rigidity
limits
your your choices and
and and if you are willing to give up
rigidity if you're willing to give up
being right
in my case if you're willing to give up
being shyness
or being shy if you declare that this
goal of mine this dream of mine
is more important than all those other
things
it opens doors it gives you
possibilities that do not exist
if you say my shyness is more important
or my
being right i have to be right
that's your prerogative you can be right
but you may not get that thing you want
as a freelancer how have you determined
how much to charge for your services
well here's my big secret if if if i
didn't have to worry
about paying my bills and being secure
that would be the last thing i would
ever worry about
i
consider myself an artist and i do this
because i love it and for that reason
every morning i wake up
and get to do it is like christmas
and i love the people i get to
collaborate with they're my friends
they're my idols they're my family
i mean it's such a joy and it's such a
privilege
practically
i have these people who want money from
me i don't know why but you know they
won't give me free housing or free food
you know drat them
so so i i do i do and and you know again
this is a song and dance this is putting
on a show because because what's that
fine line you know you get to a certain
level of experience
and you both deserve
and
need a certain level of income
and um you know but at the same time if
you're slow do you turn down less
so you know it's it's it's a fine line
to walk
um part of my bulwark against this is
having an agent and not everybody has an
agent you know but with the agent we can
be good cop bad cop
um
and
i say that with the caveat that that i
never tell my agent to be an [ __ ] i
don't want my agent to be an [ __ ]
again i i trust people you know
but but he will haggle he will in good
faith negotiate
um
and um
you know so so that's that's important
um
uh in terms of if i if
i mean look if i really like somebody
and they don't have the money i'll be
like you know what i
i love you and you're an awesome creator
and i just would be thrilled to work
with you so you tell me what's in the
budget and i'll see if i can make it
work
you know because again it just it's it's
not all about the money fortunately for
me i do have the agent and fortunately i
have a lot of clients who have a lot of
integrity and you know they will pay me
the big dollars on the big jobs and then
if there's one that's less they'll say
well this isn't quite as much
but then the next job they'll you know
they'll get back up there again it's not
like oh you know he worked for less
let's just keep paying him less i mean
that would suck
you know and i don't think that's a fair
way to treat people i wouldn't treat
people that way
but and some people would but again i
feel i'm very lucky i have i have
clients that that value me and they
appreciate that i can be flexible um and
they don't take advantage of that and
that's just brilliant you know that's
the way to be now i will also say that
my success
has harmed me in this way and i'll tell
you a story
i have a fellow i know a filmmaker who i
really respect and i really wanted to
work with him
and you know we had lunch and then a
couple months later he calls me says
brad i just got back from china
i sure wish you had been there with me
and i'm like well
yeah you know i
i wish i had been there with you too
yeah first i'm hearing about it and he
says well you know i told my producer i
said let's get brad on this
and she said we couldn't afford you
and i said i said i said well that's
funny because he your producer didn't
call me
and your producer didn't call my agent
the producer just looked at the level of
work i did i was like
you can't we can't afford him you know
or people will look at me and say oh no
no he's he's he's
he's gonna want a truck and a techno
crane and five cameras
you know and it's like it's but that's
just not true
you know and i'm guilty of that when
look i was horrible with girls when i
was a kid or when i was younger because
i just i couldn't ever
bring myself to ask them for dates i was
so horribly shy and when you don't ask
for dates you get zero dates you know
and and so i can't
say these people are idiots for making
that assumption because i've been that
way
you know they look at somebody and
they're like they just they're not good
and it would insult them to ask so don't
ask
how you handle that i don't know because
i don't know those moments that they're
having those thoughts
but i just i honestly wish people would
would ask you know because because
because look again i'm i'm not all about
the money you know it's like if somebody
wants to work with me and it's a good
job and i have the time and it's enough
money it's a reasonable amount then i
would consider it you know now if that
person again took advantage of that and
was just always nickel and diming me
well that's not gonna last i'm gonna
move on i don't like relationships like
that again i'm gonna
no matter what you pay me i'm gonna give
you 150
you know and if and if and if i feel
that that's reciprocated in the
relationship
then then that's great but if i feel i'm
being taken advantage of man you know
life's too short i'd rather not work
than work with somebody taking advantage
of me even if they're paying me a lot of
money if they're if there's some
aspect to that where they're taking me
taking advantage of me i just
you know
i you can see i don't have the mentality
to be a millionaire entrepreneur i'm not
just all about the money i you know
being an artist and and my sanity are
are very important to me
and and just being happy and being with
people i like that that just means so
much more i mean i i couldn't tell you
the the rates i got paid for the jobs
last year or the year before but i could
tell you about the the cool
films i did and the people i worked with
and the happy times
you know i just i consider money and
evil necessity that we all have to deal
with you know it's like you know i just
like i said i wish i didn't have to pay
those those pesky bills and then we
could all just make art and
you know have fun at what point do you
determine your worth
from graduating from i just want to do
really cool things to then saying well
but i do have amazing experience and
i feel like i should be paid more
um
well you're talking to somebody who
tends to have low self-esteem and i
don't have an ego
so it's kind of hard to embrace that and
i also really love what i do
i'm throwing myself under the bus here
but
i'm a pragmatist i mean obviously i've
gotta i've gotta make a living and um
you know what what comes to mind is is
blanche dubois
comment in
the glass menagerie i've always depended
upon the kindness of strangers you know
and i just
to me it's i just have to work with the
right people i i can't i i have to work
with people who respect me enough to do
the right thing
um
as far as leveling up or upping my
upping my salary i mean maybe my agent
could do that
you know but but i'm always so if if i'm
excited about a job i'm a verse to price
myself out of it
um
that's just not my gift you know even
just like um
you know mentorship and the advice i i
give i've had people tell me you should
charge for that
you know
and i think about that and it makes a
certain
kind of sense
but the problem i have with that is it's
not egalitarian
what about the people who can't afford
it i mean should they not have access to
that information
i mean i feel that they should
um
i don't i don't like
saying you are worthy and you're not
worthy and that doesn't work for me
um i want everybody who
wants to ask and is willing to apply it
now people who don't listen and don't
apply it well they
would fall out of favor
um but the people who who listen and
apply it
you know they i i want to help them and
practically speaking again there's a lot
of attrition you know it's one of the
reasons i can do those things is because
so few people
stick with it and so few people even
come to me for advice in the first place
um and and i never of course i never
i think a lot of people and again
understandably just kind of want me to
make it happen for them and that's just
not how it works
you know i can give them resources i can
point them in the right direction
you know fortunately i have videos like
this now that i can say here's a link
watch this and then ask me whatever
questions you have left over
but
you know i just
this is something i don't want to charge
for and
i will say i will say that that that as
a kind of a counterpoint there is
something to be said with having skin in
the game
because i have had situations where i've
helped people out and it was very easy
for them to throw away an opportunity
because it
cost them nothing to attain it
so you know
i don't know i'm not old enough or wise
enough to
be able to decisively come down on one
side and my compassion
is the one prevailing and saying
everybody should have access and then
you know it's up to you to put the skin
in the game it's up to you to commit i i
can't control that
what factors into you saying yes to a
project and what factors into you saying
no let me limit my answer to a
narrative to scripted narrative because
you know there's so many other
manifestations but
the one thing i would say is that it's
just got to be a great script
you know i've i've learned the hard way
that that no amount of talent
behind or in front of the camera no
amount of money can compensate for a bad
script
meanwhile you can take a really really
good script
and and have shabby technical values and
still have a really
entertaining movie
so i look at what i do as as window
dressing you know and i think it's
important of course
but but if i don't have the skeleton to
hang my
pretty pictures on then it's just gonna
be
vacuous
so the first thing is that is that i
want to see a good script
the other thing is that i want to know
that these people have enough money to
do justice
to that script
you know i'm not going to be biased if
you come at me with you know 10 million
dollars or if you come at me with 200
000
as long as you can do a good job on your
script
with that money
um if you're being unrealistic to me
that's like buying a ticket on the
titanic and i do not want to go down
with it because i'll be blamed
you know if there aren't the resources
for the crew if there aren't enough days
if there are unrealistic expectations if
there are tons of visual effects and not
enough money to pay for them it's going
to look like crap and my name's going to
be on it i don't care how much they pay
me
i'm not going to do it
so so you know a good script and the
ability to do a good job with it um and
then i look at the collaborators you
know who is the director who is the
producer um who are the other keys the
production designer who's the talent you
know the the cast
um and if there are people i'm excited
to work about if they've done or if i'm
if
there are people i'm excited to work
with if they've done good work if i know
them um
you know if they give me a really
compelling pitch
i mean all of that you know can
can play to getting me excited um
and um
you know just like with the money i
wouldn't know that they have enough time
i don't want them to tell me they're
going to do a movie in three days you
know because that's again i probably
should have said resource instead of
money i just want to make sure they have
the resources enough money enough crew
enough time
and that's not saying you have to have a
ton of any of those things you don't
have to have a ton of money you don't
have to have a ton of crew or a ton of
days but you know you can't have a shoot
with
three location moves in a day and two
crew people and
you know it's just
unless you're shooting guerrilla style
in which case i mean that's a legitimate
form of filmmaking but for me as a
cinematographer what does that do for me
i mean does that
show anything that i want to show there
are some dp's who will embrace that
because that's their jam and that's
wonderful but for me i'm i'm a very you
know painterly and interactive i mean i
want to affect the image and if i don't
feel i'm you know if i feel to me that
would be damage control if there's too
many location moves and it's just like
set up an exposure set up the camera
focus get an exposure shoot move
i'm like where's the creativity for me
and that
you know again somebody else maybe
it's there but for me i don't
necessarily feel it's there
and i might be wrong somebody might
pitch me a movie and convince me oh yeah
here you know you can do it this way and
that way again this is the whole
malleable thinking i mean i'm okay well
i would i would break that rule because
you've convinced me um
but just as a general thing i i want to
see that i can
practically achieve something i'm going
to be proud to put my name on
and won't be embarrassed by
um and then you know the last thing is
is money you know i mean um
is it a friend asking me to come help
out on a weekend
is it a movie asking me to go
to brazil and shoot for two months
um you know what is it and so uh
you know i would i would i would
consider that and if it's something i
really really want to do well i at least
have to make enough to make my bills you
know
um but ideally you know we you want to
make enough to have some savings and and
have fun and
especially when i do travel jobs you
know i like i like bringing you know
kathy with me and um we're you know and
and then we have some vacation days and
um you know like if we go to canada or
or you know wherever um just you know
turn it into a little mini holiday
because most of the traveling i've i've
been all over the world i've been to
every continent except antarctica
and um
it's 95
work travel and what i do is i'll build
in extra days you know i'll stay a
little longer or i'll go early or you
know if there's a break in the middle
but i turn it into these little
vacations and you know
it's just
super fun
have you ever turned down work
and then when you looked back on it
realized maybe it was a mistake oh yes i
have a great story
and this is a money thing too
and it goes the opposite way of what
i've been saying
so
yeah i had a friend of mine
a casting director who i really got
along with and he had cast some movies
that i shot
and he pitched me he said you know don
coskarelli the guy who did phantasm
is uh doing a horror movie and it's a
horror comedy and and they would like
you
to shoot it and it was this movie called
bubba hotep
and i thought well that sounds fun
because you know i like ancient egypt
and i like horror and i like comedy
and
they called me up and we talked and i
said oh that's great and they said you
know what's the rate
and they said four hundred dollars and
i'm like okay four hundred dollars a day
i can you know i can make that work um
and i said okay yeah four hundred
dollars a day is fine and they said no
it's 400 a week
and and either this was right when i was
starting music videos or
right before but anyway i was making a
lot of money at the time
and i'm just like i'm just like i just
can't i can't see that happening you
know and i turned it down and i was fine
with that
well turned out that they cast bruce
campbell and aussie davis in it
you know two amazing legendary actors
and it's a cult classic
and and and i just kick myself i'm like
oh my god i wish i had done that movie
you know i just in retrospect i don't
give a [ __ ] i would have done it for
free
um
but but you just never know i mean i've
i've done movies that i took a chance on
and then they came out crappy
um
i don't know i
hey
that was that's just my experience that
was that was one that i wish i had made
a different decision but but when i
looked at the cards on the table they
just didn't make sense
can we revisit your crossover moments
how did you go from
not having shot anything to then
shooting something but i would call that
a breakthrough that would be my
vocabulary for that and and those are
you know transformative moments when the
paradigm shifts
the first thing i shot was in college i
mean i don't think that that's
significant and that's probably not what
you mean but the first time i got my
hands on a camera and rolled film was in
college
but that was when as you said i wanted
to be a director
the first time after i had made up my
mind to be a cinematographer was an
interesting story and as many of these
stories are i mean so so many of the
things that have happened in my career
do not
proceed in an obvious way they're
they're just serendipitous
um
a woman
had reached out to me and i believe her
name was alice lee in houston
and um never you know she never heard of
her before and she reached out to me and
she wanted to shoot this short film
and um i had never shot anything and i
don't remember who recommended me but
i'm like yes i'm all in let's do it
and the only thing i remember about this
film
was that she wanted to put candles up in
a tree
and i remember thinking how are you
gonna do that and how is it not gonna
burn down
um and i had this buddy named fujio
watanabe who's still really
one of my closest friends
and i you know he
we he and i had met
on um
i don't remember where we met but anyway
we met somewhere um
and uh i knew he wanted to be an a.d so
i kind of got him involved so he and i
were going to do this thing and then as
often happens with young filmmakers
alice just kind of
evaporated i don't know where she went
i've never heard from her again i wish
her well i hope she's happy doing cool
things
but
alice recommended me to a guy who came
into town
to film
a
espn promo for a
bicycle race called the branders tour
and this is 1989.
and they wanted to shoot this in 35
millimeter film
um
and uh
she said i was the guy
you bless her i mean i never shot
anything i mean shot 16 millimeter black
and white in college
i knew i mean i i knew the theory and
again
as a visual artist i knew how to make a
frame and make a pretty picture
um
but that was my first job it was a
paying job shooting 35 millimeter fill
and i still have it you know i still
have that video um
and um
it's really still very good i'm very
proud of it
to this day
it was finished in you know standard
definition
um
but that's that's
how i got my first opportunity and then
i parlayed that
into doing some pickups on a movie
and
shooting some short films for friends on
video
i didn't do a whole lot before i kind of
got the
you know
bright idea to prank my parents and send
myself to houston
so so it was right after that that i was
in in l.a and doing the you know the
student films in between
you know temporary work
did you go to an agency temp
yeah
agency
remember the name perfect match oh okay
yep they were their own sort of engine
yeah i would go to those um
this mystery woman that just contacted
you you never knew how she got your
information or i'm sure i did i've just
forgotten
i don't know i mean the mystery isn't so
much that she found me the mystery is
that she just disappeared without
finishing her project and and
somehow felt
you know
good enough about me to recommend me to
this guy who came into town i mean you
know if it wasn't for i mean she's like
a guardian angel if it wasn't for her
who knows
interesting wow that's its own film
right there yeah
so then how did you go from shooting
something to shooting something
significant
but that depends on how you define
significance you know
um
there are increments of significantness
you know in my career for instance um
you know i i came out to la and i was
doing these these crazy student films
um
you know some of them were good some of
them weren't some of them i never saw
again
and then i had that moment where i
realized i have to work with people who
are doing it for a living and i started
working at concord so in a way those
were significant i'm not i'm not proud
of those films because
you know they were just super cheesy
exploitation movies but they were
significant in the sense that i was for
the first time a professional
cinematographer um you know apart from
the handful of stuff in houston i guess
i was a professional la cinematographer
i was being paid and i was working with
other professionals and i met people on
that job who remained friends to this
day one of the people i met on that job
the editor on that job edited a
california christmas
so and he and i are just bffs his name's
brett headland he you should
interview him he's amazing
he also directed a film for them he
directed a film called uh
um
something something paxton county he's
going to kill me for not remembering it
but anyways paxton county that he did
but anyway he's just an amazing guy and
we met on that and so that's significant
and i again some of the you know a lot
of those people have have you know
become very significant players uh you
know one of the guys at concord is the
ep on raised by wolves
another guy is you know directing and
producing films in south africa and
bulgaria another guy lives here in in
pasadena and produces stuff for lions
gate
you know so that's certainly significant
um in terms of films i'm proud of
probably the first one it came out of it
was the same producer i was working with
on those films
he partnered with this director who's a
really gifted guy named
rolf kanefsky and rolf had this
indie movie he wanted to make about
these kids who go into a video store
and and the video
is late and they want to charge a late
fee and one of the kids pulls out a prop
gun and things get out of hand and it's
you know this crazy movie um which was a
lot of fun to shoot um and i could we
could spend an hour just talking about
that movie because that was something
you know it took place in this one video
store and we're like how do we keep that
interesting you know and i won't get
into it because it did go on and on but
there were a lot of things that we did
to keep it always visually interesting
and not monotonous
and and it was a movie that i'm very
proud of and it also is a movie that
unfortunately um due to some contractual
matters has never been released in the
u.s and um i would love to
see that change and i have made some
efforts to try and
make that change and right now it's just
kind of in limbo but
that one is significant because it's one
of the first films that i was really
really proud of and still to this day
and at the time i was
a member of the friars club they had
this
tier where you could join under 36 and
pay a
an affordable fee and and i arranged we
had we had a premiere and we i arranged
because i remember to do an after party
at the friars club so it was very
hoity-toity my parents came into town
from houston my brother and sister um
and we just made this that was our big
hollywood night
um
and then you know one of the the
significant films that i did that the
public saw was um
a movie called cook county
which i was super proud of and um it's a
very dark film and some people don't
like it but what i always tell people is
they don't like it for the right reason
you know it's a dark we did our job i'm
not insulted by people not liking
because those people are so awful and
the circumstance is so grim i take that
as a backhanded compliment
um
and and of course you know
the music videos i shot um you know
britney spears toxic it's
i like it but it's not my favorite but
everybody knows that freaking video and
that's significant so so
i hate to kind of shotgun that answer
but but but to limit significance to
just one thing would be difficult each
of those was significant in its own way
either for me personally or or in terms
of what it did for my career because you
know without um you know the cheesy
exploitation stuff at concord i
may have never done the other stuff i
don't know
and then how did you go from shooting
something significant to shooting
something utterly groundbreaking
well
i think i'm too humble to call anything
i've ever done groundbreaking what do
you consider groundbreaking what should
i address this to
well maybe something where
okay if you're not one to let's say beat
your own chest which i respect i i find
that usually people that do excellent
work usually fall into that category
but that's just my own bias um
but something where you were taken out
of it almost as if you forgot you were
even in the project
that's where i think you really can know
something is special that's a
that's a very fair uh way to describe it
i i've had that feeling a number of
times and and i'm gonna i'm gonna take
the easy way out and and pick a
california christmas because it's the
most recent and the most fresh in my
mind
but absolutely there was an ease
as we shot that and and how did i get
that oh my god i did a social media post
and it was one of those
like it was a scavenger hunt of this to
that to this to that to that and it
began with me answering uh craigslist ad
in 2011
um which are notoriously dodgy and
you know
you'll you'll you'll reply to a thousand
of them just to get one a reply and then
chances are you're going to be standing
on set saying what the hell have i
gotten myself into
you know but at the time i had i had
gotten a few good jobs i actually got a
union feature working with name actors
off of craigslist at one point
and that was this particular job and i
the producer i worked with was a fellow
named noel vega
and really nice guy and i
hit it off with him and we stayed in
touch always good about staying in touch
you know that's another thing that young
people have to know is is you can't let
relationships go cold even no matter how
much people like you if you're not you
know if it's out of sight out of mind
you know just like your your your
friends that you
you know drink beer and and and
you know go hiking with it's like if you
stop calling them they
doesn't mean they don't love you but
they're gonna forget
so you know we would
circle back and have lunch and do
calls and emails
and really it was like six six years
before or five years
and he never hired me for anything but
that was okay because i still thought he
was a cool guy
but in 2016 he he rings me up and he
says you know i'm doing a world war ii
movie and i think oh that's awesome i
love history and that sounds big and
epic and fun
and i'd like you know to
suggest you and i said please do and and
i came down and i interviewed
with these two producers um
a fellow named leon and a fellow named
ian
and they were really nice and then there
was a director named sean piccinino and
we just
we just clicked i was like you know my
my long-lost friend you know we we just
really he was very easy going and uh
creative and enthusiastic and we just
just hit it off and so we did the movie
and we just had a great time and and one
of the things early on it was it was a
little tragic because because we i had a
siamese cat me and cathy had a siamese
cat named simon who i just i just love
so much and he was my my little soul
mate
and he had cancer and i had to go to
alameda for a week on this first week
and
i
wanted to get him surgery and i just he
was so special
that that i
through crowdfunding and some loans i
raised like 14 000 dollars
to to get him this experimental
treatment
and i was up in alameda and i remember
the day that i got the last of the money
and i called kathy to tell her and she
was crying and she had just put him to
sleep
i was just the worst oh my god even even
saying it again is just horrible
and and and so i was living with that
and i was so upset and worried that i
had gotten shingles
and and um
you know noel actually sent me home a
day early and they they one day they
shot without me
um
and i re i would have stayed i mean i'm
just that guy you know that i would have
stayed
you know wounded and bleeding but i
think he he really felt that i mean he
wanted me to finish the movie and he
felt that i needed
that break and then he was probably
right
but anyway so so
we did it and the rest of the movie was
amazing had such a good time you know
shooting these old airplanes working
with visual effects and i love visual
effects so much
one of the things i like about movie
making is just the magic the sleight of
hand you know doing something with a
camera or an object or a trick um you
know that that makes it seem to be
something other than what it really is
uh so so we had fun with that um and you
know sean and i hit it off and we we
stayed in touch
2017 the next year they decided that
they were going to add some of the
epilogue to that story where the pilots
is about the doolittle raid and so the
pilots um go to bomb tokyo in
retaliation for pearl harbor
and the
that was the part we shot
and then after that they were supposed
to land in
china
but they were spotted by a fishing boat
that was determined to be radioing their
position and and so they had to launch
early and as a result they were low on
fuel and their planes they had to ditch
their planes and some of them you know
landed in in enemy territory some landed
in the boondocks one of them diverted to
russia where they were had been
prohibited from landing um
so we went to china uh and we were there
for three weeks uh it was like i think
two
one or two weeks of prep and a week or
two of shooting i don't remember exactly
but boy was that fun gosh i love going
to other countries and shooting stuff
and you know we worked with a lot of the
local crew
i had just a fabulous time i'm a
vegetarian so everybody had a lot of fun
with you know how hard it was for me to
find food you know hear chinese food you
just always can get vegetarian stuff
and i have an aunt who's chinese and she
warned me she said it's not going to be
easy over there and i'm like okay well
we'll see she was so right
and and thank goodness we my gaffer
eddie chan who lives in you know up up
the street in shadow hills uh he he's
bilingual and um you know him and a
couple of other people it wasn't for
them i'd go in a restaurant be like i
have no idea and and honestly almost
every dish had meat in it so so they
would have to say make that but take out
the meat
um
but anyway
so it was just a super experience
and then the following year
2019 or am i skipping a year anyway 2019
uh sean called me up to do a science
fiction tv series
called salvage marines that we shot in
baton rouge
and i met even more people that i really
like you know um jamie thompson is a
producer i worked with on that who i've
worked with since and he lives in
houston
you know all this stuff is very circular
but but jamie like me is a very hakuna
matata kind of guy and we had some drama
thrown at us but you know between me and
jamie and sean we were just such
you know level-headed laid-back
generally happy people that we we made
it
so he just had all these great
experiences now meanwhile um
as early as doolittle's heroes the world
war ii movie sean had been scouted by
this company called esx
um which is run by a fella named ali
afshar who is
another really amazing fellow and he's
he's also an actor and it's so funny
because you think you know oh the
producer acted in the movie that's kind
of a vanity thing but he's really good
he played leo and and there's a lot of
people who think manny like the real
manny and leo were the the characters
who stole that movie
um so you know he's just he's just
terrific and he's such a nice guy he's
like you're your buddy you know he's
just he's he's one of the guys he's not
one of those people who you know when
you're sitting with him you're like oh
god the executive producer he's just
this
wonderful
funny snarky person
um
so
anyway
sean started working with with these
guys and they had a go-to dp in place
that you know shot all their other stuff
and they said oh you know sean we want
to work with our team which you know of
course i'm sad that that's kind of the
director i have a relationship with but
at the same time i have been the
beneficiary of that you know same
loyalty so i'm like you know who am i
who am i to be too mad about it so um
anyway sean did like
four or five movies with them that that
i didn't shoot
and then we come to california christmas
and um
that dp had some kind of commitment with
his parents and wasn't available and so
sean's like you got to use brad and and
again i knew these people because
brett the editor and the guy who did
stand at paxton county there it is brett
standing count max paxton county
brett um
they're part of the company and i had
already known them through this
networking group that i belong to like
i'm friends with the composer jamie
christopherson um i knew ali um i had
been invited to a lot of their test
screenings and given feedback so i was
known to them and so when sean pitched
me you know it wasn't like you know
who's that
and um
they they signed me up and i was so
happy you know that i i ended up getting
that job
and um
you know when i was when i was on the
job i just remember
it was it was so easy because
i mean we were dealing with covid
protocols we were one of the first films
back to start shooting
um you know under covet
protocols
we had a limited crew we didn't have a
big budget you know we had limited
equipment but again because you know of
my experience doing things like working
at concord you know i could make very
parsimonious choices you know i had what
i needed plus again the miracle of
technology with rgb leds you know i had
area sky panels i had titan asteroid
tubes you know i could do any color i
wanted i could do fire flickers they're
they're small they're bright they're
you know i just couldn't have done it
without them and i had a couple of hmis
um and everybody was just so nice um
you know josh and lauren the lead actors
i mean if
if i want to talk about
everybody who was nice i would just go
through the whole cast and crew list and
i know we don't have time for that but
it's it was just this miraculous vibe
and there were times on set where i was
like you know when this is over it's
it's never going to happen again i mean
it's this was a very special
moment and and i felt
very good about what we were getting i
knew that we had some pretty pictures i
knew we had some moving performances um
you know until something is is put
together there's always the possibility
that oh it didn't work out like i
thought
but again you know we had brett as the
editor brett hedland and he is just so
good and i've known him for so many
years
i've never seen him cut anything bad
ever
and
you know jamie the composer did a good
job and uh
keith roush the colorist
you know it's just it was just one of
those things where the stars aligned and
it was magic and
i wish i could take credit for more than
just a tiny fraction of that
you know great recipe
but you know everybody else did their
part everybody else
brought the magic and
um
you know you can't plan things like that
you can hire the right people you can
green light the right script and that's
certainly hedging your bet just like
when we were talking about success
earlier you can't you can't
100 invoke it but you can you know you
can hedge your bet in that direction and
they really did they made the right
choices they chose a really good team um
you know daniel aspramanti our line
producer
did a hell of a lot of work
you know making the
right decisions in terms of the covid
in terms of you know the budget you know
how to allocate it i mean we never he
and i never went round and round about
anything i tried to be reasonable i said
you know what numbers do you want to hit
on these equipment packages and i went
to my vendors who i had relationships
with and you know between me doing some
horse trading and then you know giving
us a little generosity we we just made
it all work um
and caitlyn epperly too who um is
daniel's girlfriend she and and jamie
wrote these just friggin amazing songs
um and i hope they get released because
some of them there's just a snippet of
them in in the movie but i've heard the
entire songs and oh my god they just
should be hits they're so good
when is it time for an artist to get an
agent that answer is going to be
different depending on whether you ask
the artist or the agent
um
you know
popular media has done a great
disservice
to creative people in the expectation
they have created for what an agent does
because there's this whole
mythology that agents discover unknown
people and turn them into stars and
build their careers
and in my experience that is is is
it's like a unicorn maybe it happens i
don't know those people i've never had
that agent
um
and when i tell people this they're like
well what do you pay them 10 for
and oh my god they take 10 of the jobs
you get yourself
and i say i say
they they bring the value because my
agents at least negotiate my deals
and typically though if nothing else get
what they call an agent fee which means
the client pays the 10 percent
um sometimes they get me more money
sometimes they get me more per diem
sometimes they get me a better hotel
room
but even if they didn't do any of those
things there was a cachet and a prestige
to having an agent
and at a certain point in your career i
think you are expected to have an agent
um
having said that i know some really
prominent people who don't have agents
you know just like some of them don't
have cars and you know bill murray
doesn't have an agent he has an 800
number so if you're bill murray you can
do that um
but
you know
i i i just
the reality with an agent is i don't
think any agent
agents agents are it's again we have to
remind ourselves we think of ourselves
as artists we think that this is art and
we are creating art
it's a business everybody's in this for
business you know except lunatics like
like me
and um
those agents make 10
and if
you make diddly squat 10 of diddly squat
is not going to look good on their
ledgers and so they're not going to sign
you
um they don't they're not in the
business of investing in people and you
you know you might say oh well that's
kind of harsh and you know why don't
they take a chance but again remember
there are
all those successful working people out
there remember we were talking about the
volunteering why would you work for free
it's like who's gonna pay you when there
are a hundred experienced people over
here that they could also pay so why is
an agent going to build your career when
there are all these experienced people
who don't have an agent who are making
a good salary you know if they're going
to invest they're going to invest in
those guys and they're still not going
to invest in those guys
so
you know it's it's you really kind of
have to be in that position where where
your numbers are worth you know cashing
in on
and the other thing is typically um
agents will aid when you're when you're
at that place an agent will will seek
you out you know you've you've won a
festival award and and that could be an
exception too i mean maybe if you just
had this amazing festival film maybe
they would roll the dice on you but
that's probably in anticipation of the
fact that you know netflix and hulu and
amazon are going to be offering you some
some opportunities
um
but uh you know there are people you
know who feel you can get out there and
cold call agents i i early on had an
agent you know who i just sought out
but but
they didn't do much but take ten percent
and you really have to consider that um
uh you know why are they signing you and
and if if they're just if you're just 10
to them
then then
and and they're not a brand name they're
not a recognizable agent i mean is that
the right thing and i i'm not saying it
is or it isn't because i don't know i
mean you know maybe that little bit of
prestige is a thing that you feel works
maybe somebody would hire you also
thinks it works
but you have to realize that that the
premium agents the people at the big
seven
they are who they are because of their
their rolodexes you know they can pick
up the phone and call those people you
want to know those people you want to
know will take their calls
um they'll answer their emails and you
know
joe joe nobody they're not going to take
the calls and they're not going to
respond so
you know it's all it's all a matter of
influence and uh
i do feel like you know sometimes
there's projects i want to work on and
i'll tell my agent you know and i'm
saying you know make a call to these
people and you know let them know i'm
interested and do you know anybody do
you know this person do you know that
person um
you know but but by and large you know
my agent is not calling me up with jobs
every week it's very rare they send me a
job and and they don't call me up with
with new clients
and i've talked to some peers and a few
people have slightly different
experiences but by and large this is the
average this is what you know most below
the line agents are like and i think
most director's agents too um
when you ask that question to the artist
the artist is going to say i want an
agent right now because they have bought
into that mythology you know they think
that that i'm talented i'm good i have
something to show and the only way i'm
gonna break down those doors is if i get
somebody to walk me in and i need an
agent
and and it's just it's just not true and
it's it's it's not going to happen for a
lot of people and just like i said
earlier
if if your thinking is rigid such that
next step is agent you don't get agent
you're stuck
you're lost you know you have to you
have to negotiate past that roadblock um
because you know maybe you will get an
agent you know maybe you get an agent
later i mean i've had several agents
but um you know the thing is is that my
experience in this business is even when
you have an agent you still have to do
it all yourself it's all on you
everybody and again it's a human thing
because look i would love for somebody
to show up and say oh brad you know here
let me take you and get you this meeting
and here's a job and here's a limo and
we're going to take you to your new
house in beverly hills and
you know that's that's the dream isn't
it for every human being but it's just
not the reality i mean just like
again there's the exception sure that
happens to some people you know but if
it doesn't happen for you does that mean
you're gonna stop
you know i've been a very
working class
filmmaker all my life and i've had
agents and i've been a member of the
canadian society of cinematographers and
i've been a member of
you know the international
cinematographers guild um
i've done a lot of things and i have a
lot of associations and a lot of friends
and you know sometimes you know noel
vega will call me up and suggest me for
a movie that leads to a bunch of other
stuff and that's great and it happens
you know but i can't wait around for
that to happen i can't
i can't
um
make
achieving my goal dependent on an
external force
or an agent you know it's it's really
again like i said i have an agent i've
had an agent for quite a few years and i
like him i think he's a really good
agent but
you know i'm not waiting around for him
you know i i he does what he does and
that is you know um
that is just complementary to what i do
i i run my own show uh i just recently
had for for california christmas shawn
and i hired a publicist
and we really liked our publicist and
it's something that i did because i had
wished i had done it earlier in my
career and i really didn't um you know
because you you're on films and you're
with companies and they have publicists
but eventually you come to realize that
those publicists are not publicizing you
they're publicizing the movie or the
stars or the production company or the
director
um you know but if you hire your own
publicist that publicist is publicizing
you
so um you know but even with this
publicist on i still
had several days when when the movie was
blowing up on netflix where i sat in
front of my computer posting and
answering and emailing
literally all day and i wouldn't stop to
eat and i would work through the night
and into the next day like a crazy
person and my you know kathy was like
you know you're good you're gonna hurt
your health you're insane and i said you
know kathy this movie is not always
gonna be at number one and while it's at
number one i have to do this if i if i
don't do this
and people have forgotten it's going to
be too late
and people could say i'm a crazy person
and i didn't have balance and maybe
they're right you know i mean how do we
ever know that we're doing the right
thing but but in that moment i felt
that's what i needed to do and so that's
what i did
um
but you know you asked about agents and
i gave you a life philosophy
but i like that
how would you handle it if you were
working on a project with great people
magical great chemistry
but they're a little bit behind on
paying you
how would you approach that
what what do you mean by a little bit
behind
a couple months
if i'd be a long project um
i'd hand it off to my agent i'd tell my
agent to deal with it you know and have
they have a legal team and
i i would i would keep doing i mean i i
certainly wouldn't
confront any of my creative partners or
probably even tell them about it um i
mean i might if i felt they would have
influence with the production company
you know but i wouldn't threaten them i
wouldn't be one of those guys like i'm
going to walk off
you know again
i'm committed to the work first and even
if even if those bastards never paid me
i'd i'd finish the job and never work
with them again
you know but but but to me somebody
else's bad behavior is not a license for
me to also have bad behavior
um you know again if somebody's being
unsafe if somebody's being jeopardized
you know or harassed or harmed that
would be different i would certainly
you know become defensive and
confrontational in that
responsibility you know as as
you know to whatever degree was was
necessary in the moment but you know by
and large i believe in diplomacy and
professionalism
and and if it's just that my pays late
i certainly wouldn't be happy about it
but i'm not gonna harm the work and i'm
not going to harm my relationship with
the parties who are not directly
involved in that
you know predicament
how about earlier in your career when
you did not have an agent
well
you know it would it would still be a
similar strategy but i
i would not jeopardize my position on
the project i would i would not go into
defcon mode until after the project
wrapped
you know and even then i wouldn't be you
know impolitic about it i would you know
i would be professional i would you know
i would give them notice and then i
would either get a lawyer or i would
you know file a complaint
with the labor board you know i would
you know do the right things if i was in
the union i would you know where i mean
i i am in the union now but if i was at
the time i would report it to the union
that's the other thing too is if i was
on that job in addition to seeking my
agent on them i would stick the union on
them
um but but if i was all on my own i
would like i said i would just wait
until
you know i would not be happy but i
would put up with it until we were done
and then i would go through
the you know the legal
avenues available to me
and and if i ended up getting boned in
the end and even if i didn't even if
they ended up paying if i had a bad
experience and felt they were being
predatory i would just never work with
them again
you know to answer that it's like look
you know in in withholding my pay
they're already harming me right
you know but if i pee in my own well
then that's adding harm you know if i if
i
um
provoke them in such a way that they
spread you know bad stories about me
even if they're in the wrong i don't
know who they know
you know if if the producer or the
director or my you know the actors you
know if i create a situation
where they think i have some bad
behavior you know that's gonna harm me i
don't you know there's no value in that
to me that's just that's just adding
adding my own harm to it
um and i just don't think it's going to
improve it and that's that's just based
on my value because again i'm their
first and foremost for the work and the
relationships
how much time do you spend each day
improving your craft as a
cinematographer well see that's one of
those formula questions there's there's
just no formulas there is no
bullet point on my calendar every day
um
i nebulously engage you know i read the
news i read imdb pro news i
engage on social media i belong to
networking groups i belong to
you know
groups specifically about film lenses i
belong to
cinematographer groups i belong to
professional groups like the canadian
society cinematographers the visual
effects society and you know i look what
are people talking about you know what
are the articles they're posting i might
come across an article and post it
um so it it it's really i mean i do my
due diligence and i do my check-ins
but if if if it's a day where there's
really nothing
on those boards or on the news then then
i probably don't do too much if it's a
day that there's significant amounts of
stuff you know if i have the time then
then i'll be watching some videos and
reading some articles um
you know
maybe bookmarking them if i don't have
the time uh you know i do i do i'll do
webinars and and workshops and you know
in in a normal area era where we're not
in a pandemic i'll go to trade shows and
product demos which you know in as much
as they're important you know to
learning about your craft and the new
technologies they're also networking
opportunities um and it's fun to me it's
not it's not it's not work i mean again
these are these are toys it's like
what's the new toy what's the cool thing
you know it's you know instead of a 4k
camera you have an 8k camera and why
should i care you know and um
you know now you've got these affordable
anamorphic lenses where did those come
from and how are they different from the
you know
tens of thousands of dollars lenses and
uh um
you know now you've got these rgb leds
that could do any color under the sun
and they can do a cop light and they can
do a strobe and they can do
you know fire flicker and i just i love
that because cool that's a new toy and i
you know either rent it or go out and
buy it
so
again there's no i can't tell you how
many hours a day but but it's certainly
you know
one of my focuses it's one of the things
that uh that that um you know just like
when somebody reads the news they check
you know the the the national section
and the international section and the
the comics and the one ads for instance
it's like you know that's one of those
things that you know every day i'm like
okay what's you know what do i need to
check with
how much time do you spend trying to
book your next job
i could say 24 7 considering i have a
website
you know i have i have posts and
and and social media identities on
linkedin and you know to me that's like
little fish poles with bait that are
stuck out into the into the water 24 7.
um
you know i i network i plant those seeds
i have people out there that i hope are
recommending me and saying good things
you know maybe you would call that
passive but to me that's all
you know
sometimes those would get me more work
than me picking up a phone or or asking
or going to lunch you know it's those
it's those those ripples you put out
into the world you know just like you
obviously did your research on my
website i didn't have anything to do
with that
um i mean i created it but i you know
you and i didn't talk about it
um
in terms of in terms of me personally
you know it really depends on the days
um when when when california christmas
was blowing up i was looking at imdb
films in pre-production and just
reaching out to people you know because
i thought you know now's the moment i
can you know reach out and say hey i've
got a number one film
um
but you have to balance that you know
with life and i could easily be a
workaholic as i've already kind of let
you know that i would work through meals
and through the night um
and you know
i
i
network and and hustle
far more
than i shoot you know there's this great
quote
by uh
um
orson welles
and it's something to the effect that
you know he
he he
probably made a mistake becoming a
filmmaker
because it's you know two percent making
movies and 98
begging for the money to make them i'm
paraphrasing but that's the essence of
part of that quote um
and and it really is i mean so much of
our work is getting work what i i like
to tell people that i am professionally
unemployed
because what most people do only a few
times in their life in between jobs
i do constantly even when i'm on a job
i'm looking for work you know
so so really
if you looked at how i spend the hours
in in my day
i'm professionally unemployed
when you first started out was it the
same percentage of time that you were
looking for work
absolutely not and and that's naivete
you know i really felt
build it and they will come
you know i really felt that um
i mean i had never been a freelancer
before i didn't understand
the dynamic of working as a freelancer i
didn't understand the importance of
networking i had only ever worked for a
company where they
meet you once and they hire you and then
you just keep showing up and you know
doing the time card until you quit or
get fired
um
so it really was a huge learning curve
for me and and there were a lot of
illusions just like when i moved to los
angeles i thought oh you know it's a
huge city somebody's gonna hire me
somebody's gonna give me a job and i was
so
full of [ __ ]
you know and i guess mercifully so
because because if i really realized how
hard it was gonna be would i have done
it
probably but it i wouldn't have been as
hopeful and optimistic it would have
been more oppressive to live with the
reality of what lay ahead of me instead
of being blissfully ignorant
do you think working at these temp jobs
prepared you because it's the same thing
like when you would work at these temp
jobs and one of these things would end
and okay accounting doesn't need you
anymore i don't know what you were doing
but
and then you had to go and let the temp
company know i'm available this week
yeah i mean
in little ways i think because
because like you could wait for them to
call you if they had a job for you
but you could also wake up at 6 00 a.m
and call and say i'm available and you
were more likely to get something you
know so there was that incentive be
proactive you know
and um
i'm not a morning person i mean left to
my own devices i wake up at 10 so for me
to wake up at 6 00 a.m that was a
superhuman feat
it's not so hard if it's a call time and
i'm getting paid but you know just to
cut you know wake up and make a call
because maybe i'll get paid to go to a
job that i really don't want to do
oh my god yes well you know
we also don't want to go to the clinic
and get shots but we have to so it's
just you know i'm at that age now you
have to get a colonoscopy every five
years it's i'd rather go to disneyland
but you know there are things in life
you have to do and when i was out here
calling the temp agency at 6am was one
of them and it was you know again it was
a good habit it was discipline it's like
you know do that thing you don't want to
do because you have to you know no your
boss isn't telling you to and your
mom and dad and girlfriend aren't
telling you to and if you don't
nobody's going to be mad at you you just
aren't going to work
brad how many times do you read a
screenplay before day one of filming
probably read it in its entirety at
least twice
but then
like i'll read the individual scenes as
the director and i are planning them
you know like
i don't read the script front to back
but i will revisit the scenes like how
are we going to light this when we're
scouting
when i'm ordering equipment you know i
go back through and i'm like you know
who's doing what somebody's standing by
the window somebody picking something up
it's day it's night um
so so you know two complete passes at
least and then
an indeterminate number of revisiting
various scenes
is it important for a cinematographer to
understand story structure i'll answer
that with an analogy it's important for
a cinematographer to understand story
structure
in the same way that is important
for a person driving a car to understand
how to read a map
because no matter how well you do it
if you don't know what your ultimate
destination is and you don't know the
path you're going to take
to get there
you are going to have problems and you
are not going to do your best job
you are not going to be able to plan
well in the case of the cinematographer
you are not going to be able to allocate
your resources of budget crew and
equipment
much the same way that the guy driving
the car is not going to be able to know
how much gas to buy and how often to
stop for it and where those gas stations
are and is going to you know end up
calling aaa
so um there's no aaa in film by the way
kids
so uh yeah um
you really do have to understand it and
um also editing cinematographers need to
understand that you need to understand
how those shots you make are going to be
used how they relate to one another and
the practical
aspects of that are
as follows
again i would
lean on a quote there's this great quote
by david fincher that says you're not
really a director until you are standing
on set
you've got five shots left to get the
sun is going down and you're only going
to get three
so you have to
decide you know which three are those
going to be and that's the same with the
cinematographer and if you understand
story structure
if you understand editing
in your mind you'll be like i need that
i need that i don't need that that would
be a luxury but those i have to have
because otherwise i can't tell it or
maybe ooh i could do it no wonder let's
just do it in a winter um
if you understand those things it gives
you that facility
and conversely
as you're shooting the scene um you may
think oh you know what the director
didn't ask for it but we need a cutaway
he he may want a moment it's like all
i've got are these two singles like like
what if he wants a moment of
you know where he wants to to cut i'm
like okay i'm going to get a shot of her
picking up the glass and him taking a
bite of his food and the waiter just
coming out and you know asking them if
they need anything whatever
i mean you know when i when i do
multi-camera shoots i always tell my my
additional camera people that if there's
ever a scene where you don't have a shot
find b-roll find a cutaway
shoot never not be shooting always shoot
me something you know get me details
and and so many times those details get
got
and i see them in the cut you know and
when we did uh doolittle's heroes i was
so proud of my team because um
we did the scene in an officer's club
and we did some scenes with with the the
cast and we had this beautiful steadicam
coming out of the actress's face
um
but
um
we ran out of time at the end of the day
now we got all of our shots but we kind
of had wanted to go get some shots of
the band just because i was like i think
we're going to need some b-roll
well i look down there and there's my
crew shooting that [ __ ] without me even
telling them
i'm like all right you know i trained
you guys well they went down there and
while we were all breaking down the the
musicians are up there doing their thing
and they guess what those shots are in
the cut
you know so so yeah it's it's you know
the more the more you know the better
you'll do even if even if you know
sometimes things don't necessarily seem
obvious you know it's um
uh
being informed is important again just
like
you know the person driving
cross-country i mean it might be weird
to think that they should know where you
know where all the walmarts are but you
know what if they get somewhere and i'm
like damn i need some wet wipes
you know i'm not saying you should do
all the things but but you know
preparation and i was i was a boy scout
be prepared
do you take any notes or storyboard when
you go through the script yes
uh i used to do it a lot when we had
paper scripts but now so many of my
scripts are digital but i'll do like a
notebook or i'll have like just a note
you know like a win a word document or
even an email
on my computer
more often than not it's an email and
i'll save it into drafts because because
if it's a word document it's on my
computer but if it's a draft email if
i'm on my phone or wherever i can pull
it up you'll be like oh yeah there it is
um
there's probably a better way to do that
but that's what i've been doing
and
i
typically only draw stuff if if i want
to use it to illustrate something to
another person
um i mean i i occasionally will do it
for myself but i have a
pretty good visual memory
in in that in that respect so if i see
it i'm
i'm likely going to remember it or i
could even just give myself a little
note and then you know
pull the visual out of my out of my
memory do you come up with a shot list
or do you leave that to the director
you know that can go
both ways i mean i feel personally that
that's the prerogative of the director
i've had directors ask me to do it and
i've done it
um if if somebody were to come to me and
say what would be your preference my
preference would be for the director to
do a draft and then let me have a crack
at you know offering suggestions you
know and make it a true collaboration
and the reason i would have them go
first is because again i want to defer
to them as the director and at least
start with the seed of their vision
rather than telling them what they
should do
um but once i kind of get into their
head and i see where they're going
i can give them you know how about this
how about that you know this complements
those ideas you know that's an
interesting idea but instead of that
what if you did this
um you know and i can use their stuff as
jumping off points
i've worked with directors before who
just don't give me a lot to hang stuff
on and and and it really is
challenging because i i want to be
deferential but you know if you don't
give me anything then basically i'm
gonna be directing everything but the
performances you know if you tell me to
do the shot list and you don't
engage with me about it you know i mean
at least
you know
talk to me about what i come up with and
let's let's beat it into shape um then
then you know
okay and you know different people work
different ways and that's fine you know
uh i've worked with people who were very
controlling and they wanted you know
to you know exert influence over every
aspect and i've worked with people where
i felt like
literally
i was doing their job and they were just
paying being paid to watch the monitor
um and then everything in between and
you know again my my favorite is some
form of collaboration whether they
originated or i originated you know i
want that interaction where where we're
building it together you know i like i
like that
how much do you plan out the day before
you shoot
100
um i
you know when when i scout
i figure out
ideally i have my gaffer and key grip
with me
but even if i don't i figure out where
i'm gonna put the lights what those
lights are gonna be
i have a sense of what the power is
going to be
i have a sense of how we're going to
move from one scene to another scene and
often as a result i will talk to the a.d
and i'll say you know that's a really
big scene and this is a really big scene
can we take this little small scene and
stick it in the middle so that that that
i have something quick to go to and then
the people could spend a little more
time on this
you know um i'm very conscientious of of
the pace of the day i don't want to go
from something big to something big
because you know that's that's a lot of
crap to move and and build up and break
down
adjacent
um you know and if it's necessary if it
has to be because of the actor
availability then then then i'll build
that into my plan for the day i'll be
like okay we'll just take a bullet on
that you know we're gonna have to
pull up time somewhere else or we'll
have to light more simply um you know
whatever that solution is at the end of
the day you have to make your days i
know a lot of people do these crazy
24-hour days and i've done them before
but i not often and not recently you
know more often than not the jobs i'm on
now are just they want hard outs at 12
hours and i'm okay with that because
yeah i don't want to
you know beat the crew to death and i i
don't want to be super tired
so it's it's kind of incumbent on us you
know to to make our days and to plan
correctly and also again when i'm
evaluating the the project initially i
want to know you know do they have
enough days to do what they say they
want to do do they have enough crew if
all of that stuff lines up then i can
expect you know that a six-page day is
gonna look like what i expect a six-page
day to look like and i'll manage it
accordingly and if we fall behind in the
day i'll make adjustments to to pick up
the pace
um you know rarely we may have to push a
scene to another day um you know spin it
off to a second unit
sometimes we actually get ahead and
we're like let's pull a scene from
tomorrow let's get ahead
you know i always like to say that
murphy's on the call sheet whether you
put him there or not
shit's going to happen i mean you just
have to account for that you can't you
can't say this is going to be a perfect
day and nothing's going to happen you
have to know stuff's going to happen and
you have to have your backup plans where
you're like if i have to simplify what
will i do um
and and have some sense of what that is
you have to know where you're gonna want
your crew to be at any given time and
and you know i'm telling them you know
i need you to move that light over there
it doesn't play now and it doesn't play
in the next scene but the scene after
that i'm going to want it and i don't
want to wait for it so get it over there
and run the power and then we'll go
inside and we'll turn the light on
it's all of that stuff it's it's just
having that that that holistic sense of
of the day
of of how long it takes to get things
done and to just make sure that nobody
is ever waiting on you
how do you know an actor is the real
deal well i would say there are
different flavors of real deal you know
there are different
there are people who bring the
performance in different ways that are
moving
and convincing but
you know it's it's really those moments
when i'm behind a camera and and i
disengage as a technician and become an
audience member you know and and i
feel a tear in my eye or i have to take
my hand off the camera because i'm
laughing so hard that it's going to
shake the camera or or
there's a scene in california christmas
that where
cali and her mom are in
uh the truck talking about her mom's
uh cancer and and every time we did that
scene i just wanted to
walk from behind the camera and just go
give him a hug you know i just had this
strong like oh my god i'm so sorry and
those are the moments for me
you know when
you know or or also i've worked on
movies where somebody played a bad
person and and you know i remember
thinking on set that you know that guy's
kind of an [ __ ]
and then and then later on like we
become best friends you know so it's
it's it's very weird you know um i
worked with rutgerhauer once and uh
my god that guy was just amazing and and
this is another one of those things that
we could do a whole one of these just
with my rutger hour stories but i'll
tell you one of my favorite ones is um
we were shooting in brazil and we were
shooting out in the uh the rain forest
near ubatuba
and we were in a hut and rutger was
standing by a window threatening
somebody and i had a low camera angle
looking up at him
and i remember i was watching through
the camera and he's like you know yada
yada yada yada yada and this chrome was
kind of his gun was chrome and you know
yada yada yada and austin he did said
something and this precise moment he did
a gesture with the gun and he flashed
the camera with a flare and i thought oh
that's
perfect oh my god it will never happen
again oh
how tragic that's i hope they use that
take so we rolled again
and
by god he flashed the camera again and
i'm like well now that can't be a
coincidence
so i go up and i ask rutger now you know
rutgers a legend i mean he did blade
runner and the hitcher and
legend and heaven knows what else and so
i'm
there's not a lot of actors i work with
where i'm a fan and i just kind of have
to not let that
you know surface up but he you know i
just thought the world to him and the
other thing is when you get to know him
because you know so many his characters
are just big meanies but he was a teddy
bear he was a gentle soul and an artist
so i go up
and i say rutgers i said are you
flashing the lens and he goes oh i'm
sorry did you not like that i don't have
to do it and i'm like no
my god how do you have that level of
control and the geometry to just get
that right
and to know that the punctuate
that that that that scene i was just
like and he was so humble and so
unpretentious
um he he would ask me you know what lens
is it is there a 50s and i would tell
him it was a 35 and he'd be like and he
would play everything inside
i never had to say raise the gun you
know you're out you know you're you're
outside your he knew if i told him what
that lens was he knew where he needed to
be
um
and um
you know i just such an amazing guy i
have to tell you one more story of his
there was another scene where we had a a
plane crash and it was
in another world it would have been a
second unit scene because it really
didn't have the principal actors in it
and so it was rutgers day off and they
had built this nose cone of a plane a
full-size nose cone and we had a field
and they wanted to just put bodies in it
and people were kind of you know going
around helping the wounded
and you know so we're out there getting
this [ __ ] set up and the director says
brad you know raise the camera and i'm
like okay so i lean over and the camera
assistant unlocks a leg and i unlock a
leg i'll lock this and we lift it up
and then she locked a leg i locked a leg
and this other hand comes in and locks
the leg and i look over it's freaking
rutger i'm like
record what are you doing here it's your
day off he says i don't want to sit
around the hotel this is where all the
fun is
he i'm sure he didn't get paid he came
out there and he was he was helping them
place background
this is rutger freaking howard is
placing background and locking tripod
legs
you know that he was a solid dude man
and and you know now bless him that he's
passed away i want to tell you that his
email address was fartville at aol.com
gotta love this guy right
what qualities are you looking for in an
actor
it seems like a strange question to ask
a dp but um
because i don't really get to ch choose
the actors
but things that i appreciate i mean i
appreciate their ability to hit a mark
um if they don't hit a mark oh you know
my poor acs you know especially on the
long lenses and the focus um but yeah i
like them to be able to hit a mark i
like them to have a sense that you know
if we follow their hands that they don't
go quick because if i'm doing a tilt and
they go you know lift it up quick i'm
gonna lose it you know have a nice you
know let me be able to understand that
the camera is following you
um
you know to be able to find their light
to have a sense that you know this if i
hold my face this way i've got good
light on it but if i look that way i got
shadows in my eyes you know some people
are just you know like a guy like
rutgers just
he's going to be there you know but
maybe somebody else i may be like you
know you have to keep raising your chin
because when you put your chin down i
can't see your eyes
um
uh
you know the ability to have again had
just have a sense of where the camera is
you know um especially with things like
stunts but
you know stunt coordinators can help
with that
um
but you know really
uh those are the things that i and of
course i want them to be good performers
because if if their performance is crap
it doesn't matter how good it looks
but you know
i work with good actors these days i
don't it's been a long time since i
worked with anybody that i thought was
wanting as a performer you know
sometimes you have the extraordinary
ones rutger was extraordinary i worked
with uh elliot gould and lainey kazan
they were just
stunning fabulous
um
you know josh and lauren were magical
you know
and again i'm i know i'm leaving out
people who i shouldn't when i cook
county you know xander berkeley anson
mount ryan donahue polly cole
you know all of those leads were just
just amazing i mean you know people
wouldn't hate that movie not i mean
everybody doesn't but the people who
just vehemently don't like it wouldn't
feel that way if those karen's
characters weren't real to them
you know and for the people who do like
the movie it's tragic for the same
reason because those characters are real
um you know whereas california christmas
was just that perfect
magical escape in the time of
covid for everybody who just wanted that
magic
and and you know they brought it and um
you know amanda detmer the one who
played the mom you know the little girl
hannah
you know i mean they were just all of
them um
david del rio who was manny ali afshar
um
um you know the fellow who played connor
i mean
that's like you know again it's just it
was just like every one of those person
was a hit and one of the things
it's a little off topic but one of the
things i loved about it which i credit
equally to the actors and to sean the
director and to lauren the screenwriter
is that all of those characters are
sympathetic i mean even the ones in with
the conflicts the ones that in a
stereotype
presentation you would you know they
would be the villain it's like they were
all complex and if you really thought
about it sympathetic so
um
you know i i just i i love all of that
kind of thing from a performance point
of view but but really again you know if
you ask me as a dp it's you know hit
your marks find your light
and and don't move so fast that the
camera can't follow you
what do you do when time is running out
and the actor does not have the lines
memorized
that's the director's problem
what can i there's not diddly squat i
can do um you know maybe they do um
you know maybe they do cue cards
um typically unless it's specified we
don't have a teleprompter and even with
a teleprompter they'd be looking into
the lens you could put you actually you
could take a teleprompter and put it off
outside the lens um
you know i don't know if i was the
director what would i do i mean i guess
i would cover it in a way that i could
try and be on angles where i could loop
it later you know i would try
you know and i i would simplify the
dialogue i would like cut stuff out like
how you know can you at least memorize
this
um
and if it was a chronic problem i guess
you'd have to think about recasting
so
yeah that's my answer
how do you know that the director is the
real deal i'm not especially big on on
judging people in an absolute way
so what i would characterize is
is is directors i am most fulfilled
working with
and and that would be
interactive ones you know
i i want somebody who both brings ideas
and has you know very strong feelings
but is also collaborative you know and
is willing to if a better idea is
presented
you know whether it's the producer or
the actor or the craft services person
is open to considering that you know
because it's it's about
the movie we are all making not about
you know their ego
um
so that's my that's my preferred
archetype
um
uh
the ones who aren't prepared
you know frustrate me
because we should all be prepared
um the ones who
you know when i say
how would you like to shoot this and
they say what do you think
a few times that's okay i mean i've
asked my
lighting crew before i'm a little
stymied do you have any ideas
but but if that is the standard mo
well i'm carrying them and it's it's not
fun for me i mean maybe it would be fun
for somebody else maybe there's you know
a dp out there who just has delusions of
grandeur and is a wannabe director who
would be thrilled to work with that
person
but for me
um
it's a collaboration you know i want to
feel like we're we're doing something
together and if i'm getting nothing from
them then it's kind of like it's just
not that much fun
and same on the other hand if i have
somebody who is
really overbearing and controlling and i
feel like i have no input
then i just you know i don't it's not
fun it's not exciting it's kind of like
i just feel like i'm
um
you know just a
i don't even know what you'd call it
just a
um a worker drone
you know just
taking instructions and not not
interpreting at all
so uh you know again to me the sweet
spot is in the middle and there's a
range too i mean you know it could be
you know a little more me or a little
more of them i mean that's okay you know
it could tilt
and and you know with with good people
sometimes it does tilt you know
sometimes you know like i said you know
sometimes you know somebody may say to
me why don't you take the lead on this
one i'm like okay let's do that you know
or sometimes they're like no i know
exactly how i want this
um
so so you know that dynamic being being
flexible and throughout that's okay but
it's it's really that when you get in
that default mode if it tilts too far
one way or the other and just every day
is like that then
you know it's that's not the thing that
gets me excited to get out of bed in the
morning
what is not being prepared
um
well not having a sense of how you want
to cover a scene not having a sense of
the type of coverage you want not having
some sense of how you want to cut the
scene
and and i will qualify this by saying
it's perfectly okay to have that idea
and get on set and have an epiphany and
throw it all away and say let's do
something different that's fine you know
but at least we have a fallback plan we
are never going to get to set and go
i i don't know what i want to do
you know then you know
time drags to a stop anytime that stuff
happens you know in my mind it's sand
going out of my hourglass to do nice
lighting
you know somebody's eating up time if
time is being wasted i'm going to have
to make up for it because somebody's
going to say light it's simpler light it
quicker shoot it unless you know less
coverage um you know that's that's where
the the the the buck is gonna stop and
it's it's depressing to me you know
in the same way that i don't want the
director waiting on me to light a scene
you know i want the people to have that
already roughed in so that when we walk
in there it comes in and maybe just some
tweaks
um in that same way i don't really want
to be sitting there waiting on
somebody else whether it's the director
or wardrobe or the actor because you
know if we're i've i've worked with
there's a particular
music video artist i worked with who
just showed up six hours late
you know
that's that person's money you know they
paid for it they paid our salaries but
you know it's like that's again that's
not why i'm there is to make that money
i mean i want you know you show up and i
show up i don't want to show up at six
a.m you know but we do because we are
supposed to and we get the thing done
and and you have the time as the
director or the actor to to make your
magic and i have the time to make my
magic
and and and that happens in being
prepared and not you know waiting for
being on set to get that [ __ ] sorted out
how do you handle a director not liking
your suggestions
um
well as a general thing i'm ambivalent
and i defer to them because they're the
director you know
if they never liked my suggestions i
would feel we weren't a good match
you know i mean i wouldn't hold it
against them i don't again i'm not going
to judge them just because their
aesthetic is different than mine you
know but we may have an incompatible
aesthetic
and that's just what my judgment would
be
but but
yeah i mean if they were belligerent and
insulting and made it personal well that
would be weird i've never had that
happen
you know but for them to say no i don't
like that idea
i'm not attached to it i look
we're all putting something in the pot
to make something amazing like i said
you know if if if the pa comes up and
gives me a lighting idea and it's better
than mine i'm gonna do it and i'll give
them credit for it
you know it's it's you know all for one
and one for all i'm not an ego person at
all i'm not i'm i'm not that way and i
don't particularly care to work with
people who are
generally speaking how much time does it
take to light a scene that is a range
between zero seconds and
infinity
okay i mean what's the scene are we
you know standing outside in a in a
close-up with beautiful backlight and
and a cliff face that's bouncing light
so it's perfect and i just turn on the
camera or
are we shooting a shot that starts in
um
you know uh uh
you know the the
the 101 freeway and and somebody's
walking down into hollywood boulevard i
mean well that would probably be
available lighting but or or is it like
a steadicam shot where we we walk into
this house and we walk through the back
and we go into the neighbor's yard and
across the street you know i'm saying
it's you can't there's no generic answer
it's like it's like it could be simple
it could be complicated
you'd have to you'd have to give me a
specific scene and even inside of a
specific scene i can say well here's how
long it would take if i wanted to do a
really good job and if we don't have a
lot of time here's an abbreviated
version
so in california christmas when we first
see
them sitting at the kitchen nook or the
breakfast table and we're finding out
different things about the characters i
don't want spoilers i don't want to give
too much away but that there's an issue
yeah um and i think it's a daylight
scene it looks like it's more morning i
think they're making breakfast how long
did it take to light that scene this
beautiful light thank you um
20 minutes maybe um but uh i had it
roughed in before we got there you know
we didn't wait on it that was already
set up and we walked into it
ah okay so you're talking about 20
minutes once you walked in no oh okay
took the guys who went over there to do
it 20 minutes while we were shooting
something else and then we got there and
while the actors were getting set and
the props were getting set and the
camera was getting set the lighting crew
tweaked it and did not infringe upon our
time at all
ah okay but
the sun went down
so then we had to put a silk over that
back window
i don't know if it was that scene but we
shot you know we block shot a whole
bunch of stuff in there um i should i do
we didn't block you that's not that's
not correct we we shot
we would move the cameras around between
the scenes but um
but you know we shot all of the scenes
in that space at the same time
and uh
when the sun went down i had to cover
that front window with diffusion so if
you pay close attention at a certain
point you're seeing detail out there and
then it's just white and and so that
took a little bit of a reset and we did
have to wait on that because we were in
the middle of that set but it wasn't
long i mean it took um i don't know five
five ten minutes to reset that
but you know the barn took a long time
you know
that barn we had them in there pre i had
a we were on a shoot and i had we were
on a day and and i was like okay let's
shoot exteriors so i can spin the crew
off and get them started on that barn
because it's gonna take a long time
so
you know and also the bar the bar took a
while and that was i was nervous because
we did not have a pre-light but we we
did it so that we started small we
started on a small area of the bar and
as we were shooting that behind us they
were finishing the lighting
but that's just another thing is like
you know you do not want to wait you
want you want to get up shooting as fast
as possible
how do you decide when to move the
camera well again i primarily defer to
the director
um but but i'm not one of those people
who likes gratuitous movement i've
worked on shows there are certain
styles of filmmaking or gratuitous
movement and she's like always keep the
camera moving i i like it to be
motivated i like there to be a reason
for it to be moving
um
and and i just intuitively it's like
when i'm in that space i'll feel that
moment where i'm like you know we really
should go from here and then slide over
to that person or you know just how cool
we got to follow them in through this
door and outside
i would probably like to move the camera
a little more than i do
but when you move the camera it can
complicate lighting because you have to
hide
stands you're seeing more of the space
um
you have to have a you know
and i
if i was given a choice between moving a
camera or doing cool lighting i would i
would probably do the cool lighting
i know people who do
less than cool lighting to permit more
camera movement and
you know that
again that's a legitimate aesthetic but
it's not my preferred aesthetic
um
but but in a perfect world you could
have both um
um and again like i said i just uh
unmotivated movement
it's a distraction i i just i think even
with lighting i mean you could do cool
lighting that doesn't complement a scene
you know and and uh it should never be
about making yourself look good it
should be about complimenting the actors
and complimenting the story you know
telling telling that story in a way that
the the people lose themselves in it um
you know one of the things that visual
effects artists often say
is that is that our best work is the
work that nobody notices
and i feel that that's that's kind of
true for me i mean i always like it of
course when people say well that was
really pretty and that was beautiful but
but i hope that it's because
it complemented that moment and that
they you know they saw these two people
in love and it was just so beautiful um
and not that it was like distracting in
some kind of way because that's not
you know that's that doesn't serve the
the the higher purpose that we're all
supposed to be there for
when you shot the video store
one location yeah teens sort of sounds
like the thriller yeah type movie
what were you focusing on movement or
lighting or how are you making it
interesting within that one space
well
you know there was there was a little
bit of all of the above you know the
director rolf kanefsky is
you know just
really passionate about coverage he has
lots of different ideas about about
getting
a variety of coverage on scenes um
and again we had motion where we needed
to have it um
and
some of the things that we did to keep
that movie interesting um
you know in the beginning of the movie
they're all standing up and they're
talking
and
so we
kept like the top half of the walls had
colored bands on them and they had
colored neons
and the bottom halfs of the walls were
gray
and
so we came up with a design
where the lighting would evolve and um
in the beginning it's just you know a
very
neutral
fluorescent lit thing with these these
neon signs and
then this this conflict occurs
and at first people it's like all fun
and games and so they turn off the
fluorescent lights and i'm motivated
from those neons i put my own lights
above them and i match those colors and
it's like now it's kind of a nightclub
so i'm like you know they're they're
having fun it's kind of a nightclub feel
um and then then things get more serious
and and those lights go out and there
was a there was there was a dramatic
motivation for that to happen um and
then there's a confrontation where these
spotlights are shining through the
windows and it became almost monochrome
and and the angles there were a lot of
angles like this so you're not seeing
the colored bands anymore you're seeing
the gray you're seeing the ceiling
so all of those things you know it was
like
i remember thinking man if it looks the
same for 90 minutes it's gonna be so
boring and and
it's not going to be dramatic and so the
delighting had to be a partner
with that story and and and create those
those moods
and you know to ralph's credit he
created that justification in the story
and with the characters
and and we had just a hell of a lot of
fun with it it was you know
one of the things i love about both that
movie and california christmas is the
variety of looks
you know
i do like i love the look of of cook
county but it's mostly this kind of grim
raw
look which is a cool look
but
like in california christmas you've got
the breakfast scene and you've got the
barn at night where they're you know
lifting the food and you've got the
party with the red and you've got the
bar with the blue and you've got outside
the bar usually you've got all these
different looks and that's just man
that's so much fun and and and those are
the ones i'm proud of
and and so it was the same thing with
this movie tomorrow by midnight is you
just have all these
really different looks and and then also
as a for an audience member it
disconnects them from what came before
because it's like you know okay this is
visually this is a whole new thing you
know we've gone to another place and
and that was important for the story and
it was important to keep the visuals
fresh again so people aren't just going
oh my god it's that wall again
how does camera movement make a shot
better
the first thing that i would say is that
is that
camera movement does not automatically
make a shot better it can make a shot
worse
um
you know that would be like saying
how does drinking a margarita make
things better you know
sometimes it does
and there are other times that well it
probably wouldn't be the best thing
um so
you know in in terms of um
the ways in which it does make it better
is you know for instance if we if we're
slowly moving into somebody as they're
having a realization
and that that dawning is happening on
their their face
and and as they're having the
realization we're pushing in we're
getting close we're getting intimate
we're getting uncomfortably close to
them the audiences you're like you're
carrying them along and you're like oh
my god i'm right in their face and that
emotion is just huge you know that's
awesome you know or or if you're
discovering something you know you're
you're in a steadicam and you're
following them and it's like what is it
you know what and you see them and
they're looking and what are you it's
like oh my god you know whatever um you
know things like that where you
were you know again you are
the
audience's proxy you know and and and
how is it interesting to them is it
interesting to them to just sit and
watch these people talk blah blah blah
blah you know or or do we feel we want
to take that audience and let's get them
in closer you know or let's do a move
where we suddenly don't see this
person's face you know and they're going
to be thinking why don't i see that
person's face you know what what are
they saying what are they doing what are
they looking at you know
i have this really f
favorite story from rosemary's baby and
um the cinematographer was talking about
there's a scene where ruth gordon
is
on the phone
sitting on a bed and and and the
camera's at the end of a hall
and the director said okay you know set
the camera up so he you know he got ruth
gordon on the bed and she's perfectly
framed you know within the door and he
sets up the cameras this great shot and
the director comes and says no no no
move the camera we'll move the camera
over and um he says okay he moves the
camera over and the director says no
move it over some more and he moved it
over so far
that all you see is ruth gordon's back
you don't see her face
and this guy's like okay well that's
really weird
so
they finish the movie they go into the
theater the dp's sitting there watching
an audience watch the movie
that scene comes on the audience goes
to see around the door
now that's not an example of a move but
that is an example of
what where are you taking the audience
with your camera you know and and and
really that's the when you get them to
that point
you know where they are like
so engaged with this two-dimensional
projection of light
that their
primal instincts kick in
and against common sense they lean to
see around the corner you know again
just like the the idea of the steadicam
where you're leading them
you know through this place it's like
you you're building anticipation what am
i gonna see i'm with that character
what's gonna happen to them what's gonna
come out of over there you know or or
you know that emotional moment where you
get right up into the face
um so
you know again to me to me that's really
what it's all about it's about it's
about
you know with the audience like how are
you
pushing those those primal buttons in
such a way that even a non-verbal
proto-humid would respond to
what have you been the most terrified
on set and what is the scariest shot
you've ever gotten well the most
terrified i ever was on set
um
gosh years ago now i
worked on this mtv show called senseless
acts of video
and
the premise was that they took
scenes in music videos crazy scenes that
were achieved by vfx
and replicated them as stunts
and
had some good time shooting that that
was a fun shoot
but there was this one particular
scene we had this guy named troy he was
our stunt man
and he had what's called a wing suit
and in base jumping that's people who
basically just jump off of buildings and
cliffs and crap with a parachute
so pretty scary stuff
and and one of the things in base
jumping is this wing suit where
like rocky the squirrel you spread your
arms and these little bits of material
come out and
i mean it doesn't you know it doesn't
keep you aloft but it lets you
kind of rather than going straight down
it lets you get a little bit of soaring
before you deploy your your your your
your uh
parachute
and uh we were shooting in the grand
canyon where he was gonna jump off
and i have a fear of heights and and
part of my fear of heights is because
i'm kind of clumsy
and and i just you know
i don't want to stumble over something
and
go over the edge because i'd be that guy
i'd be the guy in the news that went
over the edge
and um
i remember we were shooting in an area
that was that was native american
territory
so it didn't have the fences and the
railings i mean it's literally just
there's the edge there's oblivion
and and and some of the guys are like oh
my god let's go look over the edge you
know oh that's awesome 1800 feet down
brad come look come look like hell no
i wouldn't get within six feet of that
edge i figured if i'm gonna fall i'm
gonna have
something to land on
so i didn't do it and um
because of the nature of the stunt we
had a lot of cameras and this was these
were like tv sports cameras you know the
ones with the really big lenses the
super long zooms we were shooting it on
video
and and i think i had gosh six eight
cameras plus i had a bunch of cameras
mounted on this there was also a plane
um
and uh
i remember i got there and i and i asked
the crew i wanted to be fair i said
i said i said who's afraid of heights
and nobody said they were afraid of
heights and i said fine
i'm going to be on the camera at the
bottom of the canyon
and you guys are going to be on the ones
around the edge
um they cabled them in everybody had
like a cable tied off to a stake or
something
um
and the cameras were just right there
and i was like oh my god but but i would
take a helicopter
go down which was also interesting
because um in the canyon because the air
is going through the canyon it's very
turbulent so as you go down it's like ah
but even i was okay with that because
you know as long as there's something
between me
and
eternity i'm i'm i'm okay so i even
though that was uncomfortable it was
much better than standing at the edge of
the canyon
um
but later on after we rap some of those
guys were like i was just [ __ ]
myself and i'm like you said you weren't
afraid of heights
i was i was being diplomatic because if
they had i mean i don't know what i
would have done drawn straws or
something but but i wouldn't i would
have tried not to make anybody who was
uncomfortable do it but that was that
was to me the scariest moment on set
um
in terms of the scariest shot wow
um
i i don't i don't have one off hand but
i'm
i'm
well i do i do have one actually yeah so
we had uh you know this was 2002
and there were no digital cameras there
were no gopros and i had an arie 3 which
is you know big 35 millimeter camera and
we were mounting them onto bikes to get
these really hot shots and we had one
mounted on the left rear tire of a bike
and and it was mounted with this rigging
called doggy cam which at the time was
new and it was these thin rails as
opposed to speed rail which is this big
you know big much more rigid stuff
and the the stunt was that the bike was
supposed to drive right at this car and
at the last minute veer off just a near
miss
and um
so we rigged it
now one of the things was we had so many
stunt riders on that that that we had
exhausted
at least as i was told we had exhausted
the experienced people and they had
brought in trick riders people from
vegas who do hot you know hot rod stuff
that's you know not necessarily
precision movie stunts
um and i don't know if this person was
one of those i really don't but we did
have some people who were taking chances
that you know the director of the second
unit director who was a professional
writer he was like you know don't do
that that's that's not what you're
supposed to do um but these guys were
hot doggers um but anyone this
particular one
i remember i was sitting
standing on the road and i see in the
distance this car coming and i see him
just getting smaller and smaller
and then all of a sudden there was like
this explosion of black
particles and he he veered and i
realized what happened is he got so
close that the camera impacted the front
of the car
blew into a billion pieces
and i'm like my god if that hadn't been
doggy cam if that had been speed rail it
would have twisted him up under the car
and he would have been dead
and i'm just like son of a [ __ ]
and and and and the line producer who
you know thank god is still a good
friend today but he was so mad
understandably that that camera was
destroyed and he's like brad you
destroyed a camera and i'm like i'm like
i'm like mike i
it was rigged where it was supposed to
be it was rigged appropriately
and that dude just did not
time his move he did not gauge his
distance and i just you know
i hate i hate you know making excuses
but i'm like i had no control at that
point and you know thank god it was
rigged safely so that it fell apart
instead of taking him under the car
so yeah that was probably
one of the scariest because in that
moment i was like my god you know what
happened and is that dude gonna die
how long did it take you to get over to
where that you saw him get smaller and
smaller i don't even remember i don't
even know if i went over there i
probably did but it's like
that's the only part of it i remember is
like son of a [ __ ] and i and and i just
remember that thing blowing into all
those i just i wouldn't have thought a
camera could do that you know it just
shattered
what does having a california christmas
reaching number one on netflix mean to
you that's an interesting interesting
question that i have i have actually
wrestled with because
it was
absolutely unexpected and i i really
really was in shock
and and i was gratified and i was
grateful and i was so happy to be part
of that special holiday season for
people and i was so happy to hear how
much they enjoyed it
um
[Music]
i've had a lot of success in my life
and i've always kind of had
this
illusion
that that would be
a turning point you know where i would
have this big moment
and and
things would would evolve in just this
amazingly positive and prosperous way
you know like when
i won the vma for moby or when britney
blew up or
you know when
county was in theaters you know i've had
these moments
and and
invariably you know i've i've not
had the expected results and i've i feel
like i've been disappointed
um and i always kind of you know felt
like oh this is my moment to level up
you know
and um i mean obviously i have leveled
up because you know i'm doing cooler
stuff now than i was then but but you
know we all have ambitions to be beyond
where we are
and and i've just never fulfilled my
hope for that
and um so when when the movie came out a
lot of people were conflating its
success with mine and they were saying
oh you must be so happy you're gonna do
so well you're so lucky
and i'm thinking well first of all i
have no profit participation in this
movie i got a flat salary and i will
never see another penny from it
um
but the other thing is i really i got to
the point where i got like really
uncomfortable like really emotionally
uncomfortable and i was thinking that
you know what this is
is that i just i am a very humble person
and i'm uncomfortable with compliments
and attention and the spotlight you know
but i'm still going to be grateful and
appreciative
you know i used i had i had this
girlfriend once because i was
uncomfortable with compliments tell me
you know just shut up and let them say
nice things you know and let let them
feel good don't don't you know because
i'd be like oh no it's not true
and it's like well she said that's not
polite that's not nice
but anyway so i let them have their
moment but this dissonance really
bothered me and and then i i kind of
realized later on
that that i was in my mind i was like i
can't get my expectations up with this
hyperbole you know this overwhelming
hyperbole from all these people because
you know to hear them
say it it's
you you know gonna be all sunshine and
rainbows and you know limousines and
award shows and i'm just like that's
probably not going to happen and i i
can't let myself buy into that because
because it's it's
it's
the come down is really hurtful and and
the higher the expectation the worse the
come down now i'm not saying good things
aren't going to happen i mean good
things already have happened you know
but but but what i don't want is that is
to get my head so up in the clouds
because those good things will happen
regardless of of
my expectation for them
um and i just don't want to have that
disappointment i would rather be
pleasantly surprised by oh that's nice
you know than thinking and hoping
and and then it's just not realized so
it was it was a it was a complicated
experience and and i tried to always be
present to be grateful and appreciate
the moment and
um
somebody said to me well it was a shame
you couldn't enjoy that and i said i
said well
i did in the sense that you know
again i consider myself an artist and i
created something nice and people
appreciated it and and that's enough you
know i just have to know that that's
enough that's you know
just like i told you earlier what was my
contract with myself my contract was
that i would be an artist and anything
beyond that is a bonus and and if i
remind myself of that and i keep myself
grounded in that
and i know that people appreciate it and
and i look at that enthusiasm and
hyperbole as an
expression of their
experience then then it's it's very it's
still gratifying i'm i'm humbled i'm
glad i mean it's you know we don't all
our projects don't mean that much to
people and it's nice
you know i mean it's nice if i create
something and it's meaningful to me you
know like those those guys who did all
those bugs bunny cartoons you know
the chuck jones he said um you know we
weren't trying to make them for kids you
know we made them for ourselves and
they found an audience on saturday
mornings and people thought they were
kids shows you know and same thing with
this i mean when i'm behind the camera
i'm i'm not thinking about you or those
netflix viewers i'm like
what do i like and what make what i
think is pretty and and i believe that
the director and
the producers and netflix you know are
trusting my aesthetic because i've
demonstrated it and and so i'm just
doing that aesthetic i mean if somebody
specifically said oh i want a hair light
or i want this shadow i would create
that but one of the things i do take as
a compliment is is i very seldom have
people tell me to change stuff you know
i just do what i want i do what feels
right and then they're happy
um so that's that's you know my
experience with the movie maybe a little
more complicated than you were expecting
no it's really interesting you know
someone once told me this advice
in relation to something similar what
goes up must come down
and i never and it was so weird because
i was literally thinking about that last
night so maybe i was i don't know it's
just weird but
there's a lot to that and that's not to
negate good things happening yeah but
knowing that at some point it will come
down and to not be devastated by that
well and the higher you go the further
you have to fall
i really was cognizant of that i was
like oh my god you know this is huge and
if i write it it's oh my god i'm just
gonna
be shattered
[Laughter]
so i just i didn't emotionally again i
just i reconnected with the reason i did
it i didn't i didn't do it for accolades
i mean it would be nice strategically if
if somebody
wants to hire me for something and i get
some really cool jobs and clients
because again that's just more creative
gratification and working with cool
people and doing nice things that
hopefully people will enjoy you know
but it's a it's a means to an end the
the the adulation in and of itself is
uncomfortable to me
how did you find out that the film was
number one on netflix i think sean
texted me the director um
it was either that or i saw a facebook
or an instagram post but i i'm pretty
sure he texted me we were all in shock
look we knew it was a fun little movie
but it was a little movie it was a
little
you know cute little thing that we did
and it's
all of us have been involved in
stuff that
going into it seemed like a bigger
project if that makes sense you know we
just thought this was a little bitty
sweet christmas movie um and you know
the fact that it just
i mean my god it was number one in the
world for eight days i was looking at
individual
countries i had friends in
france and the philippines and canada
and
um
england and wales and
uh
colombia and and brazil and they're like
oh my god we saw your movie we love your
movie i'm just like oh wow you know i've
never had that i've never had a
simultaneous global release ever
never
um i mean maybe those music videos but
that was
15 years ago and the internet didn't
exist in the same way it does now
it's just it's just oh my god i just
like all these people
talking about it and loving it and
wishing me well
and i mean somebody in the philippines
somebody in russia is watching my movie
and and um
and they're liking it and it's like well
you know you can't you really can't hope
for more than that i mean i was looking
at those
those charts
and we were above both grinch movies we
were above jim carrey we were above the
animated grinch movie we were above like
literally all this other stuff
when i looked at the at the rate
rankings
california christmas was number 13 for
the entire year of 2020 over all other
genres of movies
and that's
only more incredible when you consider
it was only in release for two weeks
a 26th of the year
and it was number 13. our little teeny
tiny movie
over all the george clooney's and
jennifer aniston's and
you know wow you know that's cool and
i'm glad i'm again i more than more than
getting full of myself i'm glad people
enjoyed it i'm glad that it was a part
of their christmas especially now when
so many people
are having a hard time i'm glad that it
was a distraction i'm glad it made them
smile
i'm going to read the first page of
california christmas and as a
cinematographer maybe you can interject
and
tell me what you think of different
parts that i'm reading
exterior northern california skyline
morning
in a soft glide through a cluster of
clouds we ascend above multiple wine
vineyards and rolling hills until san
francisco's skyline emerges in front of
us so i knew as soon as i read that that
was stock footage i mean i knew the
scope
of our of our film and and
i knew that our only aerial would be
would be with a drone that couldn't get
that kind of altitude and distance
and the funny thing is is is
more than a few people have have emailed
me and their
compliment is oh my god i just loved
those aerial shots of san francisco and
the bay bridge and i'm like well thank
you i will pass those compliments along
to the stock footage company
which you know they always take in good
humor but um
but yeah
funny anecdote i wondered how you got
those those they i don't think they
wondered they trusted but i had i had to
i had to tell them that well that's the
dream but it's only a dream
because you would have had to do it with
i mean it would have been a helicopter a
helicopter right a drone
at that altitude
a drone won't rise to that altitude and
you couldn't get that kind of distance
with it
you know it's not going to fly into the
over the bay and into the city right
okay yeah because that's have you been
on that bridge did you drive over that
i'm sure i've been to san francisco many
times but i don't specifically
someone is afraid of heights okay well
in a car i don't i only care when
there's nothing between me and and the
and the drop if i'm in a car or a
helicopter or i don't you know even if
there's a high railing i'm fine we soar
over the golden gate bridge until we
arrive at an upscale building
interior van aston hotel suite bedroom
morning
sunlight pours into a beautiful
high-rise hotel suite as
joseph van aston25 attractive with
egotistical confidence enters the
bedroom from the bathroom wearing only a
towel so so when i i i heard that i mean
i felt it was a penthouse kind of thing
which which would have been challenging
because you know when it's a when it's a
penthouse i mean
unless you've got the money to to you
know lower a scaffold outside the the
building you can't light from outside
fortunately we landed in in this really
cool um structure which was part of a
hotel it was a it was a banquet area in
a hotel that um we treated as a bedroom
and it was
not only was it not a high level it was
actually
slightly submerged but there was this
really nice high window that you
actually see in the movie
and um
that was you know i have these wonderful
lights called m18s which are
these lovely hmis i mean they're just
such a go-to hmi and and i i
put one out the window and
that was a scene we didn't have a lot of
time for because they wanted us out of
the hotel we we had somewhere else to be
originally i was going to do two hmis
out that window and we just didn't have
time we just we just did the one and
fortunately it works perfectly i mean
looking at it i am like i don't even
know why i would have wanted the second
one and really i would have used it to
create more depth but the director
didn't want the the camera there anyway
so uh it all just worked out fine but uh
yeah i put that i put that light in
there and it was you know pretty hot and
spicy and i was a little bit worried
that maybe it was too hot
we modulated it some um and you know
then in the end i've had some people say
that that's one of their favorite scenes
he throws open the closet door walks in
interior van assen hotel suite walk-in
closet morning joseph grabs an expensive
suit off of the rack and rips the tags
off of it the towel drops to the ground
around his feet when i heard that i
figured you know
um closet we're probably gonna have to
build
a little piece of a set
because you know any real closet you're
not gonna get the camera far enough away
from him to get behind
the the clothes i guess if you had a big
walk-in you could pull back and just
set some clothes in the foreground
um
but for whatever reason i was thinking
that you know we would have to build
that and and as it worked out again it
was a banquet room and that door that he
goes through is actually it just goes
back to a prep area where are there all
these trays and and um you know metal
things and and and racks and crap and we
just cleared out a space and and we shot
a little corner but it's actually a
really big big like if you turned around
there's just you know tons of room
filled up with junk um and then we you
know we pulled the camera back and and
we stole one of the wardrobe
department's rolling um you know
wardrobe hangers and we just stuck it in
there and uh but again we had to shoot
it really really quick and that was one
of those things where like with his feet
and the
the
towel dropping i mean literally
i was just trying to get it in place and
like roll roll roll i was like oh my god
you know
so we didn't get a i mean the shot looks
fine but i didn't get a finesse it was
just kind of like whatever the lighting
was by the time i got the camera down
there because they're like shoot it
let's get out of here we gotta go
interior van aston hotel suite bedroom
morning joseph steps out of the closet
fully dressed in his suit he looks
fantastic
then looks at his phone with a cringe
insert phone gemma three missed calls
i think they ended up cutting that out i
don't think they've got the gemma stuff
oh i see okay all right well
no i'm just saying i i don't i don't
even know i don't even remember if we
shot that
okay trying to remember i thought he had
some kind of a phone but well he has it
when he talks to his mom
but does he have it in this scene maybe
he does
oh i'm not sure because he's dealing
with this this gal that's in his bed
yeah i know a chunk of this scene was
cut out and i'm trying to remember which
piece it was i think it was the stuff in
the closet it's either cut out or it's
truncated
oh okay well here we have
jasmine oc in a sing-song voice joey
joseph looks up from his phone to the
bed there is the gorgeous jasmine 20s
naked in the bed just waking up before
she can speak joseph grabs a room
service menu and brings it over to the
bed i remember i remember when i read
that i was like what's this naked stuff
because i'm thinking a christmas movie i
don't know
it's california
well you know lauren wrote it and i
think that girl is a friend of theirs so
who knows but i mean she was wearing a
what do you call it a camisole
uh so she wasn't naked okay but you know
that was that was that was funny i
remember i remember thinking oh my gosh
you know because anytime you do nudity
it's like there's some sensitivity and
clear the set and and that's all good
but it slows things down you know
because you have to clear the set and
i'm just thinking well that's going to
complicate stuff but you know in the end
like i said i think she had a camisole
on and we just did the
you know the blanket and a quasi
quasi-suggestive way and and and there
you go and i think that you know i
really like the way that that that sun
looks the the light looks and it's it's
so funny because i think when i really
get it right you know it feels like i
didn't do it and i'm just looking at it
going wow that looks cool i wonder who
did that you know i don't i don't feel
the ownership of it when it when it
really just
you know goes straight down the track
like that and and you know the flare in
his in his face which is a little
of an a stylistic non-sequitur because i
don't think we have a lot of other
flares but it just works so well in that
scene and it was so beautiful and and
maybe if i'm being honest it's a tiny
bit gratuitous but i think everybody
liked it and i think it's pretty so
there you go
joseph handing the menu breakfast
breakfast is on me checkouts at noon
she grabs the lapel of the suit jacket
and holds him close
joseph denies her kiss with a smile he
hovers
to say i have to say he played that so
much better than i pictured it in my
mind i just love the way he played that
scene and
but the coverage and
it really turned out a lot the way i
pictured it in my mind when i read it i
mean i felt that it really
you know because things don't always do
that i mean sometimes you you picture it
one way and then you get there and the
location's different or the actors play
it different or the act you know the
director wants to cover it different and
it's not quite what you picture but i
that that scene really did play out kind
of the way that i imagined you know
apart from the fact that his
the way he did that that kiss avoidance
was just so so much better than what i
imagined it would be
right and she says joseph continued soft
i'll call you
jasmine makes a pouty face and i think
if i remember correctly she says no you
won't yeah
yeah that was perfect yeah
okay
that was an interesting it was an
interesting way to to introduce joseph
and it was it was wonderfully succinct i
mean you you sat a lot
you said a lot in that that little tiny
scene to just to set up what kind of a
playboy and cad he was
and and i think that that made his um
transition more meaningful you know when
you saw that he actually
was falling in love with this
you know tough country girl
right who came from two separate worlds
you know he was used to always hearing
yes she was probably always used to
hearing no she wasn't taking any [ __ ]
from him
brad can you take us through how you lit
certain scenes for a california
christmas we have this one here where
lauren is on the phone yeah that's a
scene in in cali's bedroom i i remember
it's on the second floor
and when
sean said he wanted to shoot in that
bedroom i was like okay
i'm gonna have to get an extra high
stand so we gotta we specifically
ordered an avenger stand for this shot
and then also there's a scene in mom's
bedroom where she's sick and she's bed
bound that one also we needed that
avenger stand because a normal stand
would not get us up to an altitude where
we could get a a good angle like we'd be
pointing up
so so that's a special stand we shot it
in the day with an m18 which is the 1800
watt
hmi par i remember in that moment
worrying that there was a little too
much glare
and uh even when we did the color grade
i was like sean you want to you know
make that go away a little bit he's like
oh no i love it you know and he was
right it's it's it's
it's it's beautiful but i'm just it's
glare is just one of those things um you
know just like a flare you know it can
be
aesthetically pleasing or it can be you
know an obnoxious artifact and and it's
just a fine line and it's it's really
nice in in this scene that was one thing
i i thought about and but this is a very
simply lit scene i mean it was uh i
think we may have put some a negative
fill behind the camera you know put some
black up just to put a little bit of
contrast in it because that light was
bouncing off of those white walls
but um
not a lot not a lot going on there we
just kept it simple and then let that
window do its thing we also we pick her
up with a camera move that a pan that we
pick her up coming in the door and then
we follow her over to where she's
standing in front of that window so
that's a a nice transition too
and i think that was the only shot we
did i
don't know if we did two sizes of that
if we did it was only two sizes not a
lot of coverage that was one of those
scenes we shot simple and quick and and
she just you know she just nailed it so
here we have the barn scene yeah i
remember when we were scouting this
angle and sean
saw that i mean behind us is kind of
just a blind little
cubicle almost like a stall but it
wasn't enclosed so i'm not really sure
what its purpose was and then to the
left
was um
a a little area with some machinery
that was kind of i i guess because it's
a dairy farm i don't maybe they milk the
cows and pump it into that stuff but i
don't know if it ended up in the movie
but that shot is actually
it was on some it was on a dana dolly on
speed rails so when we came to it we
just started pushing in pushing in
pushing in
and i'm not sure if
they used that push-in or if they cut in
after we stopped um
and it's always tricky when you're in
the shade with something bright outside
you're always kind of worried that you
don't want to under expose this and then
you don't want to overexpose that and
clip it so it's a matter of you know
finding that balance and then also maybe
bringing up the inside a little bit and
so the rim light on that was coming from
an m18 again that hmi par uh and i don't
believe there was any diffusion it was
probably just clean and hard um
and uh that was just coming from from
off camera to put that rim on him and
then i had a an airy sky panel you know
back up against the wall just putting a
little bit of fill to lift it up i shot
it on a red helium which has the
capacity to shoot what they call hdrx
which theoretically extends the dynamic
range because it shoots alternating
images it it it shoots
actually 48 frames and so one is
one exposure and then the other is an
offset exposure and then it alternates
and and that offset like if you stop it
down two stops it kind of extends your
dynamic range by two stops and then
there's a process in post where you can
bring that information back in i don't
think i used that here i i remember
thinking i used it a little more than i
actually did because when we got into
the color grade i don't know if we ever
actually invoked that even though it was
in some
shots um
but again it's just one of those tricky
things and if i had shot that on film
i'd have been very nervous and i had a
spot meter in there just metering all
those values um but as it was you know i
was just looking at the monitor um you
know i've been shooting for so long
exposing to monitors and i just trust
that if it's a properly calibrated
monitor and then i have a histogram or a
waveform that i can see the values
i've done it enough times that i just
trust that process
so i set the exposure where i wasn't
losing any information and what i may
have done i don't remember this
specifically but in something like that
is i might under expose the foreground
just a little bit you know just to to
pull those highlights down just to
ensure that they're not clipping because
i know in post as long as i don't crush
that those shadows i can still bring
them up a little bit
this is also seems like another outside
the barn or around the barn shop yeah
that is a barn but it's a different barn
but it's funny that you should say that
because we had barn as a location in the
script and they're like physically
completely different places you know one
was like for the dairy cows and then
this was more of a storage shed and
honestly you know
cooper did you know michael cooper our
production designer did a really good
job of addressing it because you know
from the outside it looks like a barn
but you go inside it just looks like a
great big storage shed you know so he
went in there and pitched that hay in
there it was kind of fortuitous because
it was such a big space and i was like
my god where am i going to hide a light
you know i mean i'm going to i want to
put a backlight on him but how am i
going to hide a light
and what i ended up deciding is kind of
like the story i told you um about the
shoot where i put the tape on the light
is i just shoved that light right back
there in the shot and had them wrap it
with black uh duvetyne so it's there the
lights there it's just dark and you
can't or the stand you get it's dark and
you can't see it and then up above the
frame is the light that's lighting them
when we shot the master scene i think i
can't remember if this was supposed to
be day or night i can't remember but
when we shot the master it was dusk
and so i had to match that so this by
the time we shot this it was night it
was pitch black so there really wouldn't
have been any frontal light on them at
all and what i did is i put a 12 by
ultra bounce out in front of the door
and then i took one of the sky panels
and i color matched it to the daylight
by eye
you know because again i've just done it
so many times that i i feel i have
really good instincts matching the color
and um dimmed it way way way way down
you know so it wasn't a lot of so it
wasn't super bright in retrospect after
i shot it i kind of wished i had made
that backlight a little warmer but
you know maybe that's noodling you know
they say a work of art is never finished
it's just abandoned
and so you know i it's probably perfect
just like it is and that was just me you
know wanting to nudge it some more um
but it was very fortunate because it
looks nice in this in this 50 52 shot
and i was thinking when i go in for
coverage am i going to have to you know
move that light around so that it's
flattering and and like so many
scenes on this movie we just didn't have
a lot of time and we went in for
coverage and it looked pretty good and
the only thing i really did instead of
moving the light is i would just angle
them i would cheat their position a
little bit to make it a little bit more
flattering so the geometry of their
position in that space
changed from the master but is such a
tiny cheat that the audience can't tell
and it would like i said it was just
made the light a little bit more
flattering on their faces
we have the interior bar
yeah you know i was scared to death to
do this bar from the time i read it in
the script and i was like you know can i
please have a pre-light day
or a half a pre-light day and it's like
it's just there was no way because it
was a working bar
and
it was too far away from our location to
send anybody off
so
it was like you're gonna have to do it
on the day of
i have worked with rgb led lights
pretty regularly now for about three or
four years
but i had never lit in a bar
seen interior with them yet
and that was a lot of lights and i'm
just like you know in the old days you'd
be sticking stuff up there and sleeving
it with gels and then you'd have cables
to run across the ceiling and tack up
and hide and then you'd drop them all
down
you know in a place that's like where
are we never gonna look or if we do look
there now we're going to have to move it
so you know there was all of that but we
used the estero titans that are battery
powered so there was no cables at all
because they were rgb led we could just
dial in the color and boom there was
blue no no gelling no nothing and and
you know our gaffer calambarus had
everything connected to an app on the
phone so he could just you know change
the brightness uh turn some of them off
um you know because in different angles
we would turn them off just because we
didn't want that spill
um and right now i'm talking about the
blue lights the cobalt blue lights which
i love that color i love cobalt blue and
and that was kind of an easy easy color
the thing that worried me was i didn't
know that how long the batteries were
going to last i'm thinking my god you
know we're going to have to turn them
off between takes and then at lunch
you're going to have to put them on
charge and he said yeah i know
they'll last and and and we never put
him on charge oh when he zip tied him in
that's the other thing is they found a
way to zip tie them into the ceiling
because and i don't even know what they
fixed those zip ties to but but i was i
was also worried about how are you going
to get them up there without you know
grip crap that we see in the shot
because you see shots where you see the
ceiling you see those tubes
but you know they look they look natural
they look like they belonged so i was
very happy about that and and the
batteries just lasted and lasted
the red light in the back again was was
kind of a happy accident because that
was the backlight for caitlyn who was on
the stage playing the keyboard and
that was one of the
rarer instances of using tungsten
fresnels
and i think those were either 300s or
or 150s that we we popped back there um
you know hanging down from the ceiling i
think what they did is they i think they
put a pole cat up you know as a small
area so they put a little like a
an extendable
metal telescoping pole cat
and then they just hung those off of
there and and you do see them a couple
of times
and they look like you know little
lights but it's like oh there's stage
lights whatever we put the red gel and
and then it just motivated that from
that direction and so it was very
natural in this shot to use it there and
then for the white light on their faces
again i used
the astera titans now i just i set them
down
on the bar
and i dim them down and this looks like
a production still because in the movie
that light's not as bright on their
faces and this is probably somebody
snapped it while we were setting up
um
but it's just so beautiful and i really
like uplight i really like the quality
of uplight but you have to be careful
with it especially you know with women
you want to make look beautiful because
if you get the angle wrong it's going to
look like a horror movie you know you
have to find that just that sweet spot
and again there's no formula it depends
on the person's face it depends on the
actions with the face
and with lauren what we did is we ended
up pulling it just a little bit closer
to josh you know to make it look nice on
her but i just i just i just love it and
um
and then in the wider shots
we didn't have it on the counter i hit
it just on the other side of the counter
so she still kind of had had that
feeling of it but when we went in for
the close-ups and we wanted to look
beautiful we pulled it out on the
counter and we found that sweet spot and
then when we reversed for him we did the
same thing we just pulled a little bit
away and we did the same thing when we
shot ali afshar for leo because he as
you know comes into this scene and one
of the things i was worried about and if
i'd had time i'd have fiddled with it i
was worried that the light on that jute
box was too bright because it's kind of
clipping out and i have no control over
that i would have had to gel it or i
would have had to make my lights
brighter um and sean said you know i'm
fine with it so we just let it go great
this is uh looks like the uh airbnb or
the
hotel that they're staying at yeah so
this this shot is in the movie
it's a place that leo
rents to put up manny you know because
they want manny to disappear
for reasons that are revealed in the
film
and that's the place that they're
renting out and i really i love this you
know because for one thing uh the fire
light now in this the fire light is just
natural fire light but when i went in
for coverage again i used the asteroid
titans and i would use i did the fire
flicker effect on them
because the fire is really not once you
get in there and you're filming it's not
bright enough to to light the faces in a
flattering way obviously for the wide
shots i had to uh go with what uh we
didn't have a cg budget to paint lights
out and i had nowhere to hide them so i
just had to go with available light for
those guys back there although you know
now that i'm looking about it there may
be a tube hidden
hidden down on the other side of that
fire pit
i guess i don't remember for sure but
anyway i just i love the the quality of
those titans when they were doing the
fire light this is one of my favorite
scenes in the movie and the other thing
is the night lighting the moonlighting
on josh and the uh yard and then in the
reverse on connor's truck
you know it's kind of hard to hit that
sweet spot because you know some people
tend to over light night and i just
gotta hate
night moonlight that's too bright and
just looks absolutely fake and then on
the other end of that spectrum is is the
moonlight that's just so bloody dark and
it's like
you know you can't see detail and you're
struggling and that might work well in a
horror movie but i think in a romantic
comedy christmas movie that's just not
the place to go
um so you know i was very happy with the
ratio here i mean it feels you see josh
clearly but it feels like he's dark and
and i love the the color shift between
the blue and the warm i think it's just
a really
pretty frame and i was very satisfied
with that here we have the breakfast
table the breakfast table yes so pretty
sure this is one of the ones which was
shot at night and we put a silk or not
as yeah maybe it was a silk i think it
was a frame of diffusion like 250 or 216
that we threw up in that window behind
there and then you see a sliver through
the door of the other room which not
only did we have to put diffusion in
that window but i had to punch more
light just to glow the ambience in the
room so that it felt like daylight
because it was just the window lit the
room was dark and it just you could tell
that something was wrong so it took a
little more time than you might think to
get this right and and by the way you
know we were talking about this scene
earlier and i said we started shooting
it in the daytime so so that ambient
light wasn't a problem then in the other
room that was another thing that had to
be added the other thing about the the
diffusion it wasn't on the window it was
backed away from the window because i
have two
m18s crossing coming through there with
a little bit of backlight so if i had to
put it up against the window i would
have lost that quality another thing is
i'm
pretty sure it was this scene it's
definitely the scene when josh leaves
when josh when she grabs his hat you
forgot something i put a couple of
stereotitans up on top of those cabinets
because those cabinets did not go all
the way to the ceiling there was a like
a a ledge
and i put those
titans up there just to give a little
bit of backlight um and this is one of
those scenes that sean likes to talk
about because there were so many people
and we
had because of the covet regulations you
know anytime we change lights or move
the camera they all had to be cleared
out
so to make that
simpler the camera is actually outside
that house there's a sliding glass door
and a back patio and the camera never
got closer than to push right into that
door and it never got wider and it never
got wide enough to see the frame so
there's a little bit of push on some of
these shots and then the other thing is
because uh the lights were outside the
window the guys could go and fiddle with
them and then those astera titans were
on an app
so in terms of turning them on and on
off and adjusting the level we did not
have to go in the room the only time we
had to go in the room is when we went in
for coverage and we popped the camera
off the
dana dolly and went inside and then they
would have to clear out and that's a lot
of people to clear out and bring back in
and then the front light you know just
to just to create that ambience behind
us um out of the sliding glass windows
was a great big uh 12 by ultra bounce uh
that was probably t-boned because it was
um it was on a porch so you wouldn't
have gotten the 12 foot heights they
probably just t-boned it and and did
like you know eight feet nine feet
whatever you could and um and then
popped a light into it and i want to say
that light was probably um
an aries sky panel i don't remember
clearly but i only had two m18s and if
that's what's playing outside the front
then it had to be the the airy sky panel
creating that that soft light and this
is another one of those scenes where i
was a little bit nervous about that that
glare coming in that window you know i
didn't want it to obscure
um
you know joseph's mom's face
um and and so we were just you know kind
of careful we would dial the level down
because i still wanted to be kind of
blown out but i didn't want it to be so
bright that you know it was it was like
fogging up her face and again it was one
of the things that i i worried about a
little more than sean did and john's
like it's beautiful go with it
so but that was that was a fun scene and
we spent a lot of time we it feels like
we spent a half a day in that in that
particular location because we had
several different day scenes and we had
a night scene and we had the the masters
and the close-ups
i'm sure that's not true i'm sure we
didn't spend a half day but you know
probably at least a good three hours you
know just in that particular space
and beautifully lit thank you well this
is a triumph because
um you know this was another instance
where
just like the bar my lights were going
to be in the shot and
and you know i had to fight the urge
because you know starting out it's a
cardinal sin to have a light and a shot
and it's funny i have to tell you a
story you know i won mtv vma moon man
for the moby we are all made of stars
video
uh there was one scene you know when we
shot that where he
has got this kind of you know long
rock and roller hair and he's
looking into a mirror and and in the
mirror i didn't notice it when we shot
it but later on i realized in the mirror
there's this little red
fresnel lens i saw a bloody light and
i'm like how did i miss that you know
and
it was red because it was gelled and i
was just like oh god you know
and uh
when they announced on mtv that that
that video had won for best
cinematography guess what clip they
played
it was like just like rubbing salt into
the wound you know here's your award and
here's your [ __ ] up
um but
anyway nobody else ever knew or cared
and if they did they're like he did it
on purpose so i did it on purpose
everybody maybe you're mocking it so but
anyway in the in the wide tilt down in
the scene you see both of them which
just man shawn had to reassure me it
looks like party lights i'm okay
and um
but what i did is when we shot them
because you're looking right at the
light source even though they're red to
the naked eye they clipped out and so
these white
rectangles and i asked um
keith roush who did the color grade i'm
like would you please
create red rectangles and just track
them so that at least the front looks
red which he did
so that's a fix that nobody would know
but i just thought they looked really
crappy all blown out they were really
good at lighting the space but and they
were really bright these bloody things
but they were not so bright that they
put the rim lights on kali and joseph
that is actually
astera titans again on just on c-stands
with the red lights and because they're
at the far end of a barn
so i'm i'm bringing those those astera
titans around to just get that sweet
spot and do that red and and you know
frankly that was that was all my idea
you know i was just like that's what i
want to do um
and then we start this scene in reverse
it's daytime
and they come driving up on the golf
cart and then they walk just inside the
doors and this happens well after we
flipped around
the sun went down so there was no front
light and i had to replicate this
feeling of the glow coming in the door
and so the light on their face is not
daylight it's that same
12 by
ultra bounce out the door with a light
popped into it and
it certainly was not the uh airy sky
panels because both of them are playing
so it was it was an m18
that was popped into that and and
because it's so dim
um
you know it must have been scrimmed way
down and probably even closed the doors
some
um you know to waste some of the light
just to create that quality um
and uh
so so that's that's what i did and
um i liked it but the the highest
compliment of all
is that is that one of maria uh
the still photographer's
shots of this
lighting setup is what
netflix used for their their thumbnail
and their advertising and i'm like you
know that's that's just you know you
can't have a better compliment than that
and um
you know you did a good job of picking
some of my favorite scenes there are
some others that i really like too but
but these are all some of my favorite
lighting um and you know like i was
telling you earlier about how i love
that this movie let me show off some
different looks and different styles i
mean if we hadn't had
you know the colors and the barns if it
was all in the house
you know we we could get dramatic with
it but it wouldn't you know you wouldn't
have the color you wouldn't have you
know that really dramatic
range of of different
flavors and so
that's another thing that i really
appreciate this movie for is it really
let me
you know have have fun with a lot of
different looks